all right and we all laugh the last word
with Laura Cognito and ebon says Friday
morning fresh out the Kerr fire
absolutely nothing to talk about
E I think we should end it quietly
overall in the world of video games
destiny doesn't have much going on no
real activity so guys it's been a great
numb just kidding we are getting
ridiculous this is a bunkers week in
both video games and in destiny I do
believe if there was a metaphor for fan
and things hitting it now would be the
time yes yes indeed a lot of stuff going
on in the gaming world so before we even
get to destiny stuff I actually did want
to cuz honestly like I know we this is a
destiny podcast but I pay attention a
bunch of other stuff too um but a good
week huh or an interesting one
definitely very interesting mm-hmm
what's been kind of your highlights
outside of destiny that you've seen this
week anything peaking your interest any
games have your attention I know exactly
what you should say here so I'm hoping
to hear as the resident ninja on this
podcast there is definitely something
peeking my hands shout out to Sucker
Punch and it's a man ghost of Tsushima
whoa hold on pronouncing it correct man
yeah I heard I said whooshing ah pretty
much yeah yeah oh man fantastic man that
is a love letter to the to the genres
and the stuff I grew up the old samurai
movies the old kung fu flicks that the
black and white filter you know with the
Japanese dub and guitar
like that's what I grew up with roseann
so like are you playing black noid oh I
might have to might be Cognito
yeah that's me that's put all the old
heads the old guys we like that stuff
listen man I tell people any time if you
have authentic cherry blossoms in your
game hey me too you gave me it sit sit
that's all you got to do this the secret
is the cherry density three comes out
and then an indie game has cherry
blossoms
we're gonna cry Lindy good job cherry
blossoms I cut too short all the fool me
black away boom oh she don't it shoutout
to the coach she's order something
that's my homegirl you would you know
about that - sure yes it is it is man
I've been I've had my iron necklace was
first announced a lot of people would
were unsure because they didn't know
what the premise was and to me what
really killed it because I know you're a
second rope guy and you're the Dark
Souls guy you guys love the Hard
difficulty it's a little do you guys cuz
I I'm too old for that I'm not trying to
break my control and be man too early
for this stuff yeah until I need cherry
blossoms and an amazing scenery and oh
shout out the pet in the Fox then the
key thing right the key thing for me
which is really cool is it's literally
two games in one you can play the
Honorable samurai way the stances the
Chi you know all that type of combat
honorable combat or you can play the
dishonorable way the way of the ninja so
I am super excited this might be my game
of the year if they pull it off man I'm
you have no idea humbly yes the court I
did see is version of Macbeth it's
amazing
yes confirmed biopic idea of the we book
listen man tell it you've read I own it
I own it man I think brought a tear to
my eye beautiful but that's been my
highlight what about you sir outside of
that cuz I'm waiting on that too I mean
yeah I played second row I've been
playing neo to yes I'm definitely in
those vibes and they had stances I was
like stances neo here we go we got the
slashing combat like I mean if he goes
Shing like slices one guy honestly like
for that one mm-hmm like I'm getting to
the PS 5 Unreal Engine demo that's
minefield we go get outta question but
like when he sliced the guy and then he
slowly dies like slowly drops and then
kind of slowly I was like aw dude yeah
like that's kind of that's like I like
that it was like it was it'd be a little
weird in combat if you're like are they
dead but it was like yeah that's how
you'd fall I mean you get slashed
showing huh it's like slow dramatic
scene I mean that game looked like a
cross of not quite breath of the wild
for the climbing but like the vistas and
the lasers
yeah like you stand open you're like hey
I see that smokes thing over Garrett and
it's like and you look like you can go
there like that I saw that breath on the
wild piece with the ninja and then the
ghost like the samurai and that goes to
sides and stances and like the smoke
bombs and it looked like he had
different amounts of health so I feel
like you might have a little bit of
leveling up in there yeah and then
there's like materials that you're
picking up I was like aw dude if this is
like ninja god of war is what I want
yeah because God of War was there's
points where god of war will kick your
butt the Valkyries are insane yeah
absolutely uh but if it's got like like
it's not good and then I finally saw the
one battle where they were against the
two armored guys yeah and he's like
hittin em it's kind of like chain block
you got two of them it's like and it
actually looks like that like I don't
want every fight just to be like shoot
he's dead sure he's dead right so I
finally my gonna we're gonna have the
which I'm telling you yeah so I saw the
two armored guy fight and I was like all
right this is what I want so that's cool
you got the horse so I've got like Epona
vibes how do you know that there's
definitely gonna be that plate on stream
for sure that a hundred percent is
coming so no I was pretty excited I've
been waiting on that for a while to I
was like please don't mess it up please
don't mess it up and so far it seems
like they did well and it was cool to
watch that and like The Last of Us
trailer i watch that recently too and
then the day before my big hype thing
for the week was the Unreal Engine so I
didn't know what was coming I saw the
Tony Hawk pro skater and I was like I
did play a fair amount of Tony Hawk when
I was younger it's like that was kind of
fun but like I was like it's fine like
wasn't really blowing me away the Unreal
Engine 5 absolutely knocked my socks off
like not in the stream I mean it was
really cool in the stream but I when I
went back and found like the 4k stream
to watch later and even my mother in
1440p so I watched it on that oh so you
you were at level I was like yeah I was
watching 1440p and I finally found like
the clean crispy version like on unreal
YouTube channel nice just that opening
section of just the light down the rocks
much less everything else but the light
on the rocks when they go in there and
they move the digital foundry did a cool
breakdown talking about kind of how the
technology works which was cool but in
the moment laying it and they're like
they're like they can do freeze frames
and break stuff down I'm like yeah you
can pick those but it was like
in the moment cough it looked so
gorgeous the detail and detail the base
of best way I can sum this up for people
who either have no idea what the hell
I'm talking about or to don't care
mm-hmm when we take like a character
right now they have a certain number of
polygons the more polygons they have to
said character the harder it is because
it's just more textures more detail it's
really hard for games to render the
higher detail you get hints white and
that's kind of an issue basically what
it sounds like they've done when they
get to the statue scene in that Unreal
demo they take something that they would
model for like a movie and then they can
just plop it in a game it still gets
affected by the lighting and everything
at the crazy high resolution but it's
not destroying your CPU and GPU just to
try and render that because somehow it's
just taking the asset from like a
modeling program it's just in the game
I don't trust me that's a technical
piece I do not understand it all but in
layman's terms they take something that
they don't have to dumb the textures
down on they keep it up the very high
res model 8 names by the way yeah okay
textures like yeah that seems necessary
and they just put it in the game now it
wasn't an actual game if you guys don't
find it later it was just a terrible
demo so that's one thing it's not a game
sad I was like I wish and I'm getting
there
and again it's Unreal Engine 5 it's it
was running on PS 5 Xbox series X is
gonna use it I mean pretty much
everyone's gonna have access to Unreal
Engine 5 so it's how they use it but
they just felt like demoing it there I'm
sure Sony was like here's some money
let's look cool I'm like yeah they've
all they've also worked exclusively in
Sony's defense this relationship with
epic and these guys has been going off
for a while it primarily Tim Sweeney
made some comments and we talked about
earlier about the I know you'll get into
the SSD aspect the about the how it's
outperforming like they say they trying
to say that it can't be done because of
the high speed SSD in the ps4 they there
they were touting that pcs couldn't even
do it based on how advanced the SSD is
in the PS 5 alright it's something to
know nerd out moment some of you guys
may feel like this is BS I did I
literally settle this stuff in my
discord and somebody was like when you
stop talking Greek I'll get back to you
so SSDs I wish I actually had one
pull out right now but my computer is on
there's a lot of different speeds
spinning hard drives is what your ps4
literally comes with and it you know
it's a slow spinning platter hard drive
picture of those silver discs then we
have all these that are like memory but
they're like just flash memory and those
are a little bit faster readwrite access
and then we now have nvme where it goes
through the PCI Express bus in your
computer and those are about six times
as fast and that's what's in my computer
probably what's in yours cuz it's on the
higher end they're run at about 3,000
gig per second the PS 5 is double that
it's 5.5 gigabytes per second compressed
which they say uncompressed if that
thing works is like eight to nine but
even compressed either way 5.5 gigabytes
per second is double what is in my
computer and I have almost the fastest
one you can get currently for pcie 3.0
now the AMD platform of chips is PCIe
4.0 mm-hmm
now there are currently that are
available one of them say like a Corsair
one for a hard drive it's at about 4.9
gigabytes per second still not quite
there still not quite there now ones
that are supposed to come out in the
fall are like the Samsung 980 Evo pro
4.0 that's gonna start to hit the six
six and a half seven maybe eight later
on so those are gonna be higher but
those literally don't even exist yet and
that's what the PS 5 is going to ship
with so they literally future-proof
their SSD and that's why if you guys
were wondering when it's like hey don't
go buy an SSD right now and hope to just
put it in the expansion port they don't
exist yet except oh if they have a
custom hardware that uses that plus
whatever else they're gonna do it's
there they're doing something pretty
unique and cool which is cool and the
series X has an SSD but they went
probably more with a traditional I think
they're probably like the very high end
of almost 3.0 very high end of it yeah
yeah so it's still faster than anything
that's available on consoles right now
but if you're gonna go like you know
apples apples for SSDs one is definitely
faster one has higher CPU and GPU and
we'll see how all that stuff works out
but just the SSDs it's a very
interesting prospect if as you said Tim
Sweeney's like
depending on what the technology is it
may be what's making some of that stuff
possible to continually load textures of
like that that's what they say big nerd
by the way giant freaking nerd so that
we love it but I love it that's going to
talk about rather that's why we connect
but yeah so I absolutely nerd it out
over the PS the Unreal Engine taken in
watch digital foundries thing about that
and they're just amazing yeah so know if
you guys haven't seen that one that's a
really cool breakdown - yes sir but yeah
that's that was my like we're getting
into this summer games fest thing now
it's kind of exciting isn't it
yeah but it's like farming here and you
know obviously things are gonna adapt
because of the pandemic but we're
getting like nice little slow news bits
each day you're what you don't wake up
what's gonna sassy scream [ __ ] hall is
gonna be 35 it's like it's like it's
shout to Prescott yeah this is dirt out
season man summertime is always no doubt
season that's when we would do the trips
to e3 we do the trips to Guardian Khan
and gcx and all this stuff you know so
this is gonna be the new way now these
little video by Knox and these you know
specials this way I think we're gonna
get a lot of this shot before it takes
me ya say it's a new wave it's a new
wave man so here's a question do you
think all of this digital distribution
is that kind of used this year where
they're forced to do it to work out
kinks mm-hmm does e3 survive or is this
like the wave of the future man it's
funny you say that because I've had this
conversation with King and um you know
he Jeff Keely is a powerful person
that's just not he's a very has a lot of
connections in the industry whether it
be publishers developers this man can
get the who's who of the gaming industry
to usually cosign what he's doing and he
has his own show now so you obviously
know they've had the disagreements with
the ESA in the direction of e3 you know
obviously we know what this pandemic I
think it's gonna come down to one how
successful these smaller shows and this
game fest stuff does right also if it
does well and companies are sitting
themselves and looking at those those
those statements those books and they
realize hey we didn't have this
money for a booth than a presence and
you know it could start signaling the
end you know I'm saying so we have to
see I think the old I will say this in
III s defense obviously my big III
supporter but um I will say this if it
continues like don't no disrespect to
the PS 5 thing but a lot of people were
not happy with the presentation after
the actual demo was completed right
after the tech demo with detective was
amazing right everybody's like that but
then some people did not like you know
the horror guys talking yeah the
Keighley and friends and somebody's
attic like nein it wasn't about that so
what that we have to pay attention to is
that if customer satisfaction is there
with the presentations because that is
that's also a factor I'm saying like
he's in control but if people don't like
the format then that could be something
that people like okay I don't know and
if the essay does something comparable
you know to combat that it's gonna pick
it put it this way the ESA is in trouble
but they're not going to go down without
a fight is really what my general point
is that's all that's it and so look for
them to try to fight back
it may be futile but who knows we'll see
yeah it's like I mean at this point
you've got a lot of companies also that
are having to try and make this stuff up
from home kind of on the fly here when
they had like I mean Microsoft
specifically had a presentation for on
stage Sony was gonna do something
different and even their plans of like
doing a lot of displays around the world
and a bunch of like in you know smaller
location none of that stuff is happening
so a lot of plans have gone out the
window either way yes so more of an
organized like hey here's this like 4k
high rig set up maybe we can switch with
like displays and switch over to the
guys at the conference breaking like
there would be more production quality
if the online stuff happens in the
future which would probably be what some
people are looking for as you said with
like Kili talking to like you know a
table of guys and it's like 4k streaming
high-res from like a t1 connection and
office all that crazy stuff is not not
the connections we're seeing that oh man
have you seen the meme though and it
cracks me up because I am one of those
is less the guy you know that's the the
meme that's like the one guy who
actually streams on Twitch because it's
like crappy webcam crappy webcam crappy
webcam have like the USB mic high res of
like green screen it's levels to it if
this is it we were in a transitionary
face it we got to see how to stay he's
gonna play out I think the other thing
that'll be interesting is this is the
console launch here if you are gonna
have an e3 still survive you this was
the year to make the big blowout for the
consoles and stuff and even if Sony
wasn't gonna be there Microsoft still
had that huge presence they were going
for with like the EAS and everybody else
smells are the big console launch is
gonna be done what's your big pull next
year that's the hard way yeah yeah
asking tough questions I know man that's
itself oh that's literally the pandemic
came at the worst time for the ESA yeah
because they were already getting
backlash and now nobody can't even go to
what was scheduled so yes uncertain
territory man I don't know what the
future holds but definitely is not in
favor of the sa I can't say that favor
Jesse well that's pretty much all that
happened this cuz week guys thank you
very much more Cognito you can't be ok
so before we get to the table yeah which
is the topic of topics for the
background if you guys are watching this
on audio just go check out the preview
of the oddly video cuz I picked the
background for a reason but yeah
so we got a quest yeah so actually
honestly before this even started my
hope was that Guardian games gonna end
we have the last four weeks of the
season I made a video about it and said
hey and more what could happen in this
final four weeks of who knows what's
going on those like alright maybe I was
like maybe we'll get a little cinematic
we'll get a tease about like us Rasputin
and Zavala and the ships and progress
and the almighty none of that happened
zero
basically apparently all the public
events that we've been doing our sputum
was sleeping through and now we have a
quest which we got from an abrasive log
and you're like hey go check contain a
Bray there's a quest whatever it said I
don't remember mhm and the quest is
called the lie oh yeah fitting as I want
take me through your login to figuring
out what was actually happening versus
what was required when you figured out
the numbers like I want to know your
thought processes this whole thing kind
of played out in your head and just
seeing what was there cuz I knew mine
mine was live people have seen that I
want to know yours cuz I texted you and
I just got like kind of a quick emotion
so I want to know like what was your
progress of like Oh a new quest so this
how we oh I want to know how it went
through with you so let me break it that
um literally the same thing man I'm like
okay look we know the calendar you know
there was nothing scheduled it was very
strange or you know on the roadmap I'm
like alright let's log in obviously
we've been treated to things like Osiris
pointing guns at Rasputin you know
little things you know obviously Doritos
appearing more you know something
exciting so there was a little bit of
excitement you boy jumps in go to Ana
Bray okay you know say actually before I
do it I want to give a shout out so I'm
actually real quick so I told you this
before I which was super dope I went to
the town of log in and this is never
happy to be on like I was so blown away
I go to the tower and I don't PC on
Steam and someone goes Cognito is that
you and I'm like he's like are you for
the last word podcast I love you go so
so salute to oblivion Ultima bear salute
to you because you made my day bro like
for like I've never had that happen
I am I still consider myself know what
did this community so to have anyone
come up to me and say yo I'm a fan of
what you guys do like salut so I had to
shout you out a bit you may but also
after that great it's only happened to
me a few times and it's just though
every time I'm like they're like are you
though and I'm like you know who is like
I don't care how
you're that still feels good that's bro
it felt good yo salute it was dope so I
owe it and we did the UM it must be the
latest down like you shall put the staff
down we stood next to each other that's
cause that was dope
anyway nothing about family in us okay
so I then I said okay let me go to Ana
Bray okay cool and um yeah she she gave
a quest and then I'm sorry what do we
got to do what's what's going on we
already know what this is for right can
I say what it's for you're gonna and I
spoil that or am I not allowed to spoil
that he uh talked about that very open
that not really spoilers yeah he got me
or NDA he got me a nano you can kill you
can go ahead cuz I think everybody knows
if you don't heads up yeah here we go
fell winters like West like yes you know
what this is so we get it and then um I
read about public events and in serif
towers so I'm like okay this doesn't
sound fun but for the sake of science
let us try to see hey I get there and
you know salutes are not getting no
Randall's getting together on one of
these things that's another thing we're
not gonna trying to organize when you
don't have any matchmaking it's nothing
so this escalation protocol all over
again in a way yep I'm looking at the
percentages and I'm like really we're
not making much progress here right so I
sat in our calculator well I wonder how
long this would take for the entire
community to do such a thing
and then I promptly said you know what
he I'm logging out I'm not doing this I
don't care about this I was like this is
time gated foolishness that I we just
came off of Guardian gate games and
trust me I did not want to do Guardian
games not only because times of
dominating it was already a foregone
conclusion but I looked at it and I'm
like I don't like this level of busywork
switch to this classic switch to this
specific class do this specific thing
dude it was just annoying if it wasn't
for heir apparent I wouldn't
done it but I got heir-apparent so now
I'm waiting for something and I'm like
no like yes shopping with areas like you
do two events and the percentage says
zero I'm like this is forceful time
gating but I want nothing to do with it
so I said you know what and shout out to
the community I want to shout out some
people shout out the pyro shout out to
T'Pol Tassie shout oh but people were
like Dave on my time they like you let's
fail this and let's see if this thing
goes up Bob that was so that was I mean
mine was pretty similar to yours areas I
don't know if he was with me in the
beginning we got together later he might
have been with me in the beginning and
we log in first thing I wanted to check
was the pyramid ships were 40 plus now
by the way right I think the ones on the
other side of Neptune there's like four
others they're not a lot of progress
this week so a little less on that front
and then I'm like hey okay here's the
quest go to Anna get this go do public
events I think we did an i/o first for
whatever reason we're just like all
right let's try IO and we do it more
like everybody still zero yeah seriously
still zero yeah yeah like everybody's
look doing the whole like John Travolta
meme looking around the room like what
the hell's going on why is this not
working and then we did figure out where
you could go in and check with like
bright echo org and you can finally see
because like dim it was classified and
you can see the number as opposed to
like the bar and we finally saw the
number because some people in my chat
we're saying I was like how are you guys
seeing like 3 million or 9 million I was
like I just want to see it somewhere
somebody finally told me Bray tech org
and I was like holy crap yeah it was 3
million public events for each place now
in comparison so this is why I mean and
I think Ares said it though at this this
came out at the worst possible time this
quest could have come out because people
have been bitching sorry but bitching
about in bounties for all season long
and then it's been a big discussion it
came up on the table two weeks ago
bounties are things where it's like guys
we're kind of getting tired of this so
the grind enos is already coming in then
Guardian games comes in the very
specific bounties everybody already
the Titan math is screwy mm-hm and then
all this still is happening and then
we're like okay so what do we have to do
down we have to do three million public
events and most people are just like if
you if I could do a meta Flake the
actual like throw your desk in the air
thing yeah that's what people are just
like screw it out I'm done I'm signing
and honestly like as the progress was
going because what I did at first I was
trying to check the math like hey how
many did we do in an hour if this holds
what's the math gonna be like how long
is it gonna take to finish this thing as
a community it was like it is nine
million let's see what the stakes and it
was like mmm okay at this pacing it
looks like it might take a week for etz
so maybe this is gonna be three weeks
and it's gonna wrap towards the end but
I was like hey this is a if this pacing
holds and then I was like I was even
streaming for like three hours and I was
like I gotta take a break
cuz I wasn't honestly sure like what I
was gonna do it was like I logged in I
was hoping to see a cinematic maybe
working on some quest steps I could go
through get a new gun none of that I
knew was gonna happen that day so I go
through the whole like the the math and
I was like okay fine
took a break did some stuff hung out
with my wife I think we ended up binging
a show that day maybe was weird you have
that's good shut up yeah definitely very
productive shut up sit by the way the
Netflix show never have I ever
okay honestly a fun little show like
it's ten episodes Paul Tassie had said
something about it and I told my wife is
hey do you want to try this we were at a
lunch break we watched like three or
four cuz they're only like 30 minutes
you actually go pretty quick and then we
just sat down
finished it that night Brody sounds like
much more interesting than what destiny
is offering it's like it's a teenage a
little bit of a rom-com type thing but
it was just like it was written by Mindy
Kaling it was just well well done can it
didn't take itself too seriously at some
points had nice and emotions like it was
a fun little show like I mean it had
some cliche moment since high school and
stuff but honestly like I got done and I
was like that was pretty damn good have
we finished in a day and but it was like
so I woke up the next morning and it was
like okay let's see how much we did in
like 18 hours whatever it was from when
it went live to now and I was like
and by pacing that thing when I thought
it was like a week had slowed way down
so now the amount of progress we had
made in that amount of time was like
this is gonna take us Lake at least two
weeks just to do a DZ and I was and
that's where my mind started to go to
and a lot of people did too
are we supposed to fail this I honestly
wondered if we were because we have the
almighty comin there has been a little
bit of a leak potentially heads up the
second mini spoiler yeah in case you
guys haven't heard I'm only gonna say
this for like 10 seconds so spoiler in
three two one potentially the Almighty
may be a chunk of it crashes and like
scrapes up the tower so that's like a
little rumor out there I was like maybe
it gets too close so when he blow off a
wing it kind of splits in part of it
lands or something and I was like are we
supposed to fail this thing and I
honestly wondered with felwinter's lie
and you see the stuff about phil winter
in the name of the quest and his bungee
trolling us and maybe they want to like
you know things haven't happened like
this before they're trying to mess with
us I'm like maybe we are all maybe it's
like it's futile maybe our efforts are
futile maybe you're s butan can't save
us or so that was weird and then I don't
know when the tweet was like was it
within 24 hours or like it was 4 o'clock
that afternoon that kind of tweet came
out it didn't take too long Bungie has
decided to change the progress of the
public events count for 5 times during
the 8th and then 10 times on the weekend
they said yeah they said this was not
supposed to take this long
uh-huh interesting huh shelter is out he
said he thinks that the wings of the
almighty gonna land and take out the
titan statue from Guardian good that's
it it's the only thing that's gonna get
hit you guess you guys are just trying
to kill sivanna
I say how it is I love it I love it yeah
man I thought that was an interesting
adjustment I don't know just a timing of
it he seemed a little curious to me
based on let's be real the backlash that
people Twitter was late that's the
community would oh my gosh so many
people were like I think M - tomato
videos like this quit there wasn't this
quest sucks but it basically was I
forget exactly his freezing on his
thumbnail I thought about making a video
but I was like I wanna
wait just to see and they did change but
it's still and this is kind of the issue
like the hate was real and I was like
yeah the mela mela it's like for sure i
mean people you just hit the community
wrong at like the perfectly wrong point
did you just like the communities just
like dude I'm done I don't even care
Season eleven could be amazing but you
messed up and the biggest thing is even
now the 5x and the 10x multipliers were
at 65% on the EDC as of this morning
which is good though we're making
progress probably gonna be about 1/3
done with the 10x and maybe if people
are like alright the community's like
alright let's screw it let's push
through the weekend see if we knock this
stuff out
maybe it's done this weekend it's still
the fact that I would love to know the
person that said even if it was 9
million and there were 3 million players
active right now it wasn't gonna take
that long why do you think we want to
repeatedly do public events II you had a
nice gentleman you're a kind soul I have
my moments cook we gotta call it how we
gotta call it this is horrible content
this this is the worst this is an insult
because again you just came off Guardian
come this is not knowing the temperature
and also we are get up we give them an
excuse we know what the resources but I
was like this is the point where they
were pot committed they couldn't switch
what they had planned that's the problem
I get that I get that but if you're
planning out your role map and you just
had a slog for how long was guarding
against two weeks to beat on one three
three weeks right and and you really
don't add substantial content it's just
really you know grind for this reward
and the bounties which retired up okay
fine and then to put that like a reset
right behind this man and I just this is
my thing in the future moving forward
this cannot be acceptable content man
this whole fake a community let's get
together let's do this we're gonna we're
gonna bind together and do this rudiment
no no no no they they got away with it
wit um was the Imperium foundation for
fractal and kana but there were some
things you work on you can invest you
could get your values you getting a lot
of guys
for apps like you can do the math or the
stock market like oh that's nothing
towards trials you're like okay you get
the thematic of it and you like you said
we will farm in God roles I mean we're
standing in front of that damn statue in
the tower forgot who knows but again
this right here the most mundane
simplistic do what you already was doing
at the start serif towers just keep
doing that y'all and come back to us
with like no that is not unacceptable
content and that's why they got the
backlash out the PC gamer today has one
of the funniest titles I've ever seen to
an article and I'm saying I was so job
I'll do loads of gave you that I was
jealous
there was like destiny oh something oh
it was sympathy effect like 9 million
people will they want not many people to
to to commit to this event and no one
could care less
Disney players say no we're not doing it
and I'm like yeah that was it was a
consensus backlash and unsettling to say
about the Mady are from buncha Matty as
a result season of the worthy is now
going into uncharted territory of the
most of the worst season in history of
that like it is literally cementing its
old we thought it could we thought we
said yo Osiris is in trouble for the
worst DLC the worst content right now
season of the worthy is not worthy it is
not worthy of Eddie woods time and here
we go again
so yeah man I don't even know how you
save it with the the arm it got a link
it we know we're gonna get this film one
two sly I mean at this point felwinter's
got to come out and you know something
we gotta get a cinema with him we
something's got to happen like this
right him this is bad it is so the other
issue that made this even worse from all
the stuff that you're saying kind of
this two-sided ways the way the public
event changed mmm so we had six weeks
when we open the towers first the public
event was the normal public event do the
public event you were getting like what
was like 14 percent or something yeah it
wasn't too crazy
at first we were going through and it
was like hey you got to do four for your
weekly bounty all right yep
then we're like hey how do we get this
like all mighty title
well it's switch now the Lord behind the
public event was as we were doing the
first six weeks we were building all
these little satellites and even by has
a good video saying hey like if you go
down you can actually see them store
down their video so we're actually
building all the satellites that
eventually we're going to need to use so
it flips instead of each public event
like building a satellite and sending it
down into the ground and the bunker what
it's doing is actually now the little
rocket comes out you'd actually see it
launch up into the air which it looks
kind of cool but when that happened the
public event got harder yes you had nine
percent progress the timer was very
tight we had like giant bosses walking
around and the biggest issue with public
events as you said we came through this
from the escalation protocol times
there's no matchmaking you have randos
and blueberries that don't know what the
hell's going on
you can only yourself control three
people in an instance unless you do the
crazy like hey you're public and I join
you and my friends invite with you and
this entire mess that we went through
two years ago or longer mmm like we've
been down this road before how we
haven't learned from this whole public
like we had vex offensive we had the
sundial how did we go from those to this
like if it was if I had to go run
sundial nine million times I would have
much rather done that yeah you know
heart deep man yeah you nailed it you
nailed it that's the again disses and we
love this game and we know we know the
nature of live service games as peaks
and valleys but what I don't accept is
what's that expression the definition of
insanity is repeating the same mistakes
you know I'm saying doing the same
actions and expecting if the result tip
yeah that's what's going on here because
it's like at the end of the day it's
like bro like you cannot in good
conscience think that we are going to be
excited for this so the only reason this
is what this is my new theory my new
theory is they're falling on their sword
they like you we don't have nothing it
has to be because there's no way they
say
in the room and said look ya'll we're
gonna do it as Claudian games and then
right after that grind we go give them
these public events for like three weeks
this movie they sat there and said this
they literally said all right look
here's the bulletin board here's the
assets is what here's the sad news show
how many people we have to work on this
we have to yeah we got ready to you BT
come to room yes bTW I did a bt came out
with a you know a little suits on anyway
oh geez oh way to try and save that this
is what we can do we can do that let
they do call and they said look they
gonna be mad
we'll just think I'll be living but we
got so much fire for them in the fall
cuz you saw what looks best says he
looks bills he's no we're not doing yeah
yeah he knew he got the heat in the fall
but we just st. got nothing right now so
we just gonna have to you know they
gonna be bad we'll take our public
lashing and that would be and this is
what's going that's the only logical
thing that makes sense because there's
no way they are too smart I'm not gonna
disrespect them because they are too
smart to know how we would react you
know they would know how we gonna react
to this so this is what this is we just
gotta say look you know and I don't I
don't get upset people anymore when they
say you bro out
I'll see you on the next yeah does
expand it now you're gonna braid over a
few months yeah yeah they're like you
know I think cuz we've ever been for
diabaté damn it I mean that's what it is
that's what it is bad and it's okay take
the break we know what's going on here
you know we all guardians we've been
around this block we played this game
for how long since what 2014 is game
existed it's a we've seen stuff like
this but yeah this is a low point and
it's gotta just be the resources and
stuff like that there's no way they do
this to us
purposely there's no way yeah it does
feel like a pension resources this is
what this season this is
the lighter season in the spring and
that's what I mean you thought and said
it's like hey it's like I know these
spring seasons can be light love the
fall stuff can't wait to see what's
coming Luke Smith replies with the four
infamous words for now that we're gonna
be waiting to see if it lives up to but
seriously what a show but acog they
didn't seem smart enough to dope how we
take artifacts that way I mean there
have been this whole season from
literally trials the bounties the bits
the guarding like this whole season has
just been just a stumble after trip over
bump in the road and it's been rough man
this has been mm-hmm this has been just
interesting choices by them to say hey
and then it's like how do you launch
trials without a depth weapons and you
think artifact power is not gonna get
completely screwed over like remember
remember remember when they started your
first your first thing you said to me he
was like you seen a requirement for
entry how's that gonna stop the hackers
then we seen the the the Noah DEP you
like how do you feel about that
we literally recalling out the problems
when the thing was first announced and
we're just like yeah and they all made
it in and they made it in so it's just
like like cheating and hackers like
that's also like dude give me an
eight-hour give me a quest that's so
long button you just don't want to
repeat it like and that's like and you
do it once and your account is just
tagged those trials worthy fine you
never have to worry about it again you
could have launched that on Tuesday
people have had three days to work on
that crap trials out on Friday the
hardcore would have been in there
everybody else could have been in there
a couple a week later you'll so it's
been a very biggest thing is I have to
say is I want to see what happens with
the Almighty
whenever this is done and I want to see
what happens with the pyramid ships as
well those are the two things at this
point for me that are gonna give this
season a hint of silver lining but
barely even that because the story at
least has some potential for what we're
going into next season in the fall so
most of the activities this season did
not play well and that's putting it
extremely nicely
season 11 potentially could be cool if
like you know the hopes of stuff getting
crazy and the fall expansion as
black-winged said all expansion has to
be massive at this point it has to be
like if you're if you literally have
like the one public event dude be like
okay you got this alright zoom call
we're looking at you we got this fall
expansion has got to be using like
everybody right now to make that thing
happen so that's that's the big stuff
yeah shout out sanity he said this is
daddy budget you said bail others facts
or salaries quick thoughts or Co dude
Tod doing SMS verification for cheaters
and people trying to really are they
doing two-factor authentication
well if that's the case salute sign me
up for that Bungie much security like
that's true ban yeah that would be cool
I have no problem with SMS verification
I mean to factors is really important so
they prevent people from doing new
accounts but yeah we'll see what happens
but that's all I got with that man so
what's going on in [ __ ] right yeah no
table real light nothing major I mean
usually the expansion the season stuff
is like a week or two before actually is
101 before we actually dive too deep
yeah what's a date wise so the season
ends on the 9th of June yeah for
Tuesday's we have the 19th the 26th the
2nd and the 9th so we have three more
full weeks win with when do you see us
getting the official announcements for
this season that comes like season 11
but I see sees 11 trying to remember how
tight it was before was it like the week
before the week before us where we're
like are we really gonna wait I wasn't
it like the way that's the vasa like the
week of a second maybe like we're gonna
be in June before we know yeah I think
so I think that they're very minimum you
know we'll see how the fell winter thing
plays out well from a lore perspective
obviously there's a lot shot the by he
knows the deal you know saying um as far
as the connections with said person and
said something hey you know so you know
that reveal I want to know if they're
gonna actually tackle it but other than
that they usually just that week before
then they lead us into you know post
almighty right you know
and how we gonna have to do how are we
gonna deal with the next thing you know
so yeah I don't anticipate anything
other than that very last week knowing
something and then it's like okay you
are now we're ready here's the deck
spending threat or issue and that's it
you know at least that's what I see yeah
I mean that's why I've been trying to
figure out in my head it's like when
does all this stuff wrap up but yeah
going into season of this one like we're
like when is this info comin we didn't
know the power level to like the week
before it was a while so yeah we got
we've got a couple weeks again with not
a whole lot on there season of the
worthy trailer dropped March 3rd and
this season started what March 10th yeah
cuz they usually do the drops on a
Wednesday usually right yeah that was
Tuesday so yeah it was it was a week
before so yeah our sighs hoping to see
yeah I mean you know we were accelerated
as far as Doritos so but then didn't eat
well see they slowed down a little bit
but they anticipate the hit next season
eat based on your your calculation sir
so I mean by pacing roughly I mean we're
at Neptune you've just got Uranus and
Saturn and we got three more weeks so if
they just kind of work their way forward
they're bound to get pretty if they have
any consistency unless they just Park it
Neptune they're close now if they Park
it Neptune for three months and then
they come in the fall
obviously that's convenient timing but
if they keep coming forward they should
be around Saturn by the time the season
ends roughly so that's the big question
so yeah I mean the swap starts it's like
Gardein games came to a close hunters
won the first day but Titans showed up
and forced to completely dominate the
rest of the vent mmm-hmm the warlocks
took home silver by the way so you did
get your silver by getting the middle
tier the whole time so I thought the
silver one actually looked good for you
guys too yeah I look fine I'll actually
like it I don't mind I'm gonna go with a
bit nice Lionel iron banner of the
season is live this is the point in the
season when I'm like I don't know if I
care like the four first iron banner
yeah the four pinnacles I'm like I could
but literally in four weeks they're
useless they're usually as we literally
get a preview down below the power
levels going up and not to beat a dead
horse the only reason why I would do
that for the pinnacles would be for
pinnacle content
such as the Grandmaster nightfalls which
we we found out me that we're not
getting much as a reward now there's not
a lot of rewards in there at least does
have right now so sounds like Iron Man I
love you but you know to you the
community has been tasked with helping
Rasputin's by completing served our
events and are currently working on the
objectives and etz the moon and i oh
we've seen feedback to the tower events
are too difficult that is hard to
wrangle up enough people to join the
cause we have had some server-side [ __ ]
we have made some server-side changes to
lower the difficulty and to help
alleviate the frustrations and increase
your success rate mm-hmm we made an
error when calculating how many
completions were required what by a
factor of 10
all right somebody move somebody moved
to Des Moines today yes yes there's
supposed to be 300,000 was 3 million or
sorry so yesterday we introduced bonus
multipliers you can read more of the
detail changes here we covered all that
to death now if you thought the like
West was gonna rustle some feathers and
make people mad oh man did did the
Twitter's the u2 did things explode
yesterday to a whole level oh my gosh
now I will say in advance we've talked
about this once already everybody should
have had their one conniption fit
already and be done but we're doing it
all over again so here we are
would you like to do you like to break
the news to the to our listeners who
likely already know what's going on but
maybe they don't yeah man max power
level shall I start going to get get in
there yeah so basically you know Luke
spoke about these plans in February
about what was going on you know and
that's the dev team and there's more
details on how it's going to work today
we're gonna talk about the infusion
system what's coming to des T to the
changes are gonna be visible starting
season 11 but won't start impacting your
arsenal until season 12 more on that in
a bit so they want the sandbox to feel
interesting dynamic you know all that
good stuff they want they feel weapons
on the primary way players interact with
the world season over the season and
what players discovered new weapons that
feel powerful interesting new perks
powerful builds and a lot so the changes
to the infusions we're talking about
today are decided to promote the
following we want you to a more
frequently earn and enjoy powerful and
standout gear right now if your
legendary weapon isn't better than the
best at current best in class there is
no reason to replace your existing
weapon with it then it says if a new
legendary weapon is better than current
best in class we risk power creep sounds
familiar
removing challenge from the game and
making the item mandatory slash the only
option for challenging activities
shutout revenue yeah shout the ready
both above points apply equally to new
bonds and perks then they says powerful
weapons can be era-defining
but eventually those errors need and so
that new errors can begin we watch
strong weapons and he goes on with that
talk about that I forgot the meta they
talk about we can't solve this by just
making weapons better than previous ones
this will steadily lower time to kill
them both PvP PvE until the sandbox is
neither fun nor tactical then they go on
about the meta a little bit more and
that to me they say they believe destiny
is at its best when you have new
desirable things pursuing when you have
active debates with your clan mates
about which of these new things to bring
into a raid and what's going to be hot
in trials next season so then they
continue so they have the legendary
weapon as far as the batch power level
will
could reach to infusion eggs now here's
the key Center job where I for kognito
breathe a little sigh exotics will not
have a max power level praise be your
man before so yes praise be the traveler
as I can the Baxter power level for
these idols will be set at the power cap
attainable three seasons after its
release season alright so this means all
legendary gear has a one year span of
time during when it can be used in
activities where being at or near the
player power cap is important so those
difficult you know powers level
activities the max power level for these
items will be visible in game in season
11 and but no items will be at their max
power level at the start of season 11
that means all your gear will be
relevant in the activity so season 11
you good is basically saying yeah season
11 we good
so at the start of season 12 weapons and
armor released in here's the key
statement your seasons 1 through 8 will
have a max power level at the season 11
player power cap skier from season 9
through 12 will all be infusible to a
new player power cat for 1 year after
their release and weapons and armor now
here's another key statement your
weapons and armor from the last wish and
garden of salvation rate will be granted
exceptions and will have a higher max
power doesn't say it doesn't say no max
power but does take higher so I'll be
curious how far your pan out yeah hi
alright so we gotta stop there yeah
you'll go for this top that was a lot
that was all gonna stop and a lot to
digest so the exotics are not gonna be
touched armour and weapons you guys
exotics you're gonna be able to use them
as long as you want that's the big one
that I know some people worried about
cog beetles over there but dab in his
head with his sweat towel who was
worried he's okay alright now just to
clarify for some people when it comes to
season numbers because even I was
talking with my chat yesterday and half
of us got confused mm-hmm season 8 is
shadow keep and undying season 9 is dawn
season 10 is what we are in and worthy
in season 11 is redacted
mm-hmm so the biggest line in this
entire thing at the start of season 12
which is the fall expansion whenever
that starts that is the fall expansion
september/october weapons and armor
released from seasons 1 through 8 hmm
will have a max power level at the C and
I like the way they phrase this stuff
racer yes I'm like a note no no
disrespect to Cosmo Age like Dylan
but sometimes the wording on this stuff
just makes it more complicated than I
think it needs to be yeah they can
literally just say the max power level
in season 11 is 10 60 season 12 will be
higher than that sees anything from
season 1 through 8 we'll never be able
to get above 1060 power level and so
let's clarify what season 8 is what
season 2 season 8 is shadow keep and
undying yes and undying Kevin's ask you
see Kevin was gay exactly it was nice
yep so undying that's what's gonna
happen
undying so stuff you got during undying
from the moon take like loud lullaby
hand cannon from the lectern for example
mm-hmm that will not be able to be
infused high enough to be helpful in the
fall expansion raid
now I feel bad oh hold on I gotta give
you the full list and then work yourself
oh go see ya give us the list give a
breakdown
oh yeah be sure to the lists I want to
go off of first this is from destiny
trials report I'm gonna give you guys
the list of weapons that are not going
to be viable in trials in season 12 so
when the fall expansion launches these
weapons will not be able to be infused
high enough most likely it's a big jump
and that's the big thing about fall
expansion it's gonna be ultimate bear
that's who you said yeah he's in check
all we ultimately to our brother Sulu
there's a little bit so you did tell you
made my day brother what a dissolute you
man
I've never had anything happen like that
to be solid I was very happy thank you
so as you guys know like shadow keep was
the start of them getting rid of first
off pinnacles that's one and then two
so trials reports first because this is
where we're gonna talk about changing
the meta these weapons when the fall
expansion launches and what we probably
get a 200 power level bump usually
something like that 200 and 250
so if our max power level and next
season is like 10 50 say the fall
expansion is 1250 200 power levels
definitely makes things pretty useless
these are what are not coming revoke ur
Mindbenders ambition beloved spare
rations those four are gone and that's
just what I can see on trials report
other than that it's exotics and trials
weapons from now
so those are already those are already
gone
so people who've been like minders
farming the revoke er is the sniper yeah
beloved's right behind it
spare rations the hand cannon of all
hand cannons also not in trials yeah
Ares has been areas was like I just got
a slightly better Mindbenders and I'm
like I'm so sorry yeah yeah yeah
shot the mellow he's asking about his
21% delirium 21% so it's like now we're
gonna go through the big boys so we've
got I'm gonna list off the major players
that I can think of Hammerhead 21%
delirium edgewise Wow
rocket launchers not really as big of a
deal Windigo Raglan wouldn't go mmm-hmm
so that's most of your heavies that are
kind of like the bigs
big players um do our rest in pieces
cabal recipe shoutouts eulogies I mean
you can go long goodbyes you can go
Twilight oath you can go Soul Survivor
we already covered beloved or a vocre
those are hot all the two heavy hitters
right there knows - yeah those are those
gonna be missed a loaded question
Aran's he'll sure that's my baby
the older questions about main
ingredient for mountaintop mm-hmm oh
well you know what I am dancing on a
grave one out that one could go right in
the bushes I am so sick of that good
Baba mountaintop I will not miss you
getting it was annoying and dealing with
it is annoying good the rest in peace
shout out it was good while it lasted
mm-hmm yes Aries mountaintop out of my
stadia try preach it preach it brother
yes of three mountaintops for three
hundreds of mountaintops oh but she got
dusk rock blues mmm
Marie told tale Mindbenders ambition
yeah those are shiny
you really gotta got rolls yeah if you
didn't get the bad of Mindbenders you
were rocking them over to facts
for me subtle calamity my boat not as I
use it in PvP but like I used it in the
dungeon yeah that was out wouldn't yeah
I've used that whole dungeons actually
so you did that was shot at the role
with me I remember I'm trying to think
sidearms there's no big players but I
mean things like some people like Drano
no drain drain autonomous autumn last
hope I mean that's let me ask you a
question last hope just got brought back
would rain last hope yeah the recent
random role that a season have done
that's what makes it that little I'll
just buy the say I was like what happens
to like interference cuz technically
those are old weapons if it has this tag
the re-release is how they like give
them life so ok so yep I just got the
car roll one I got full court spike and
crown cards I was like yes yes you've
got recluse callous mini tool bug out
bag the heroes bird showgirl subtotals
oh no we got to give a proper rest in
peace
so recluse reclusive I finally done man
that was also shadow pyro he's like just
for prospective pyro came our uh recluse
came out one year ago I know that's how
long it feels like it's been forever
doesn't have her yeah yeah feels like it
when just chillin forever devoid
submachine exit strategy on purpose that
ones exit was undying but that's still
not gonna be hanging around I also
forgot Python I think that's in there
right yeah when it was Python I'm just
trying to make sure I get like mmm
listings right Python was done so no
that one's not quite icon sticks around
so if we go down auto rifles raids
aren't there anybody been farming a
Galliard yeah galley
yo that's the joy if you don't have some
enough and you don't have but it's not
gonna matter in the fall right I mean if
har light is to join but if you want a
legendary 600
yo that's gonna hurt gali odd people
been farming gali or cream arc logic
gnawing hunger that's another one in
that 600 that's part of that that's part
of the big boy class summoner Galliard
no 100 that's the 600 Esther that's like
the three horsemen right there I mean I
can almost skip Scout rifles because
they don't really matter but
oxygen-oxygen sr3 oh how much potential
you had wait question Ola what happens
to UM the 260 joint Randy's Randy's has
gone
Freddie's we just great ran this was
undying Randy's was undines hikes I feel
like maybe didn't even get a good run
that's just me I don't know about y'all
I I didn't even finish but I'm not even
gonna finish it's funny I'm like I just
need like maybe 50 kills or 30 kills or
something like that to get Randy's to be
done with it that's the point now I mean
if you got low minimum control you could
at least check the box if you're that
close but Andy's pulse rifles we're
gonna say bygones
go figure that's the one you're waiting
on let's go figure this one go figure
but went out what does Galasso the wolf
or as least now you know what's gonna
hurt me I know blast furnace on that
list premonition blast furnace is on
their last furnace is my dad vodka
that's my dad Bob Pole yes that's the
same thing as mine just a little better
version of you that's about yeah those
pulses are gonna hurt ya hand cannons
this the one that's probably gonna hurt
a lot of people Lunas Howell and I'm
guessing not forgotten sits in there as
well mmmmmm now nation of mists is
exempt cuz it's a raid weapon from last
wish spare rations we talked about loud
lullaby Oh optative yeah burbles dagger
trust crumbles could go into Bush's
total kindled orchid your God roll kill
oh no I forgot him I got the cure rate
Oh No you know how hard it was to get
better doubles Duke Austria rose
Austrade that's some good guess service
revolver
service mama had a little good run when
180 when 180s was a minute out the 180s
when he's had a little rust original
Volvo had a good run and there's
probably stuff that I've missed but the
general idea is if you guys actually go
through and look at the age of some of
these weapons I mean not considering the
blues and the greens and the whites that
really don't matter if you go
legendaries typically if you look at the
list there might be you know 30 or
something of some of these weapons
you're gonna be able to use in season 12
you're gonna be able to use about five
of these things yeah the lists get real
small if you look at bows - no no you
literally have point of the stag and the
two rainbows so if you didn't rave you
have one bow you have one ball one bow
and the only way you get like the
kinetics are from the raids ya know so
delete my volt is what I'm hearing and
shout-out to those who are in my stream
last night actually did a vault purge
yesterday I know some people are proud
it's been a long time coming but I am
sub 300 so I'm 297 out of 500 right now
and I haven't even got to energy weapons
yet solo haven't even energy weapon in
that attic though so I know that's a big
long list but I wanted to try and go and
give you guys like the all the weapons
the bigger ones you might have thought
of basically your pinnacles that you had
in your first couple of years a lot of
those longtime ones the stuff you've
been farming a lot of places
most of that stuff is not going to be
carried into aspirational condoms the
best way I can say it now you can still
use all of those guns I listed
everything in the game all the old
content all raids it's also going to be
available what is it's not gonna be
carried into new raids new dungeons
pretty much your night falls that are
probably master and above or pretty much
anything above that base level because
that level seems to increase question
hold on it's gonna go through the list
please so for crucible you have iron
banner in trials the weapons are not
gonna be in there
gambit still matters when it comes to
invading so depends on where you care
you just may not care about invading or
you just might not be powerful when you
invade so technically you could use your
21% delirium while you kill enemies but
if somebody invades and you shoot them
with them you're gonna be shooting them
with like packing peanuts yeah so that's
gambit and then for PvE content you're
gonna have whatever aspirational Cecil
seasonal content is so picture like
heroic menagerie that one would probably
be difficult you're gonna have the night
falls that whatever high level you've
got there
raids dungeons and obviously whatever
they introduced in the fall kind of like
master nightmare hunts I imagine those
are no longer gonna be pinnacle in the
fall probably have something new
so it's in-game activities only that
this really affects you still have
patrols you can play can you can play
control survival whatever with any of
the weapons that you've had for ever and
it's not gonna change anything
basic strike playlists go back in there
with your 21% delirium main your spare
rations and your recluse and you're
still totally fine but just if you want
to do a grandmaster you can't take that
stuff with you mm-hmm
the real stuff the real guy there's been
a lot of stuff in chat people have had
like people have had some opinions about
this out there on Twitter there but if
you think so before we even talk about
like the other part of this what are you
what were your thoughts will you even
when you hit this point because we've
talked about this before we had our
debates and stuff but it seems to be
sinking in a bit more for people as it's
getting a bit more real what they gave
you a like real time when they're like 8
9 to 15 months they gave it a year
mm-hmm
right look at the end of the day and
this is what I warned people what
happened you know saying like it's gonna
hit you no I'm saying and again what I
told people about investment right
investment players what their if at at
that time sinks invested in respective
so when this happens you know and again
for the record being you came to an
agreement here with legendary right even
though I didn't like it we finally met
in the making we got the long spirited
debate yeah yeah very very we weren't
happy we're not very happy with each
other during everything but we got
through it
we was it was it was a
character-building moment for both of us
a week we got through it but at the end
of the day you know a lot of people
people have to understand this we and
I've say this in gaming community as
well overall we represent the hard-core
people who understand the hardcore
represent yeah he did the big black with
the hardcore represents a small
percentage of Destiny just that we are
the loudest we are the most
knowledgeable but we are not the most so
what happens
when the word spreads right there's
going to be that I don't say
fear-mongering but there's going to be
that impact of yo they're taking our
guns away and this is what I was trying
to get across to you guys and you even
got some hardcore which surprised me I
thought all of the hardcore were on your
side
to be honest you know and you see Toby
yeah apparently you saw what drew ski
said something you said and obviously
we've seen Destin Licari we see a big
figure is pushing back like also this
game is gonna be useless why should I
play it now and I knew that was going to
happen now do I
overall think this is better for the
game yes do our overall think power
creep is an issue and you just can't
keep that the points they're making are
absolutely correct thank God they didn't
do exact cause you thought they were mad
now and what I took exotics would have
been something else that would it took
it to a whole nother level of importance
there's a meme of somebody torturing the
destiny servers oh yeah it ate a bit
crazy you know so at the end of the day
you know I'm saying it's it's a culture
shock it's a chain we will survive we
survived what was it um Lord of wolves
wasn't a lot of wolves winning or
whatever was when he brought back
infusion I forget wonder them talking
about it which one is the I mean they've
done this before we did taking King more
stuff went away we've taken the désolée
we've gone into destiny to or the tower
exploded this is my first time your
investment over the course of time has
been removed right absolutely but again
we are the hard core we can adjust
better than the rest but if you tell a
guy that's a casual guy or a god it's
coming in destiny hey man you know
whatever whatever anything like what you
mean this is going away what the hell is
Bungie don't and then the whole thing
snowballs into what it would snowball
like the best way I can describe this to
try and give it something as content is
released right basically whatever
strategies are built for a raid will
always be viable because the weapons
technically are not going to go away and
they're not going to be able to be
infused past that content
question.what my only thing is I don't
know we get to that is they mention to
specific do we get to that probably we
mentioned to specific raids yeah do we
get to that part yeah you said weapons
and armor from last wish and garden of
salvation raids will be granted
exceptions and we'll have a higher max
power level we just don't know what that
is yet okay here's my here's my thing
what's up we'll abide
some people would say last wish and
garden of salvation are based on pay
walls you have to buy Forsaken you have
to buy shadow keep leviathans free so
that's one that if they do sunset those
that's free content now though
potentially and it's also not random
role so it was a different time for two
different things right so here's my
thing they least need to reissue those
cuz what's the purpose of even running
those why would what is the incentive to
run that's the only negative I have I'm
wit yeah I have thought about I'm like
it's very interesting they use those two
so I'm like yes you're making a good
point leviathans driving out of the
solar system and that's a big lore
narrative question mark in that I have
no idea what Aria now animals versus
male taking raids away
is pitiful content removing that I mean
it's not even pinnacle anymore it would
be
that would be forget it no I mean
that'sthat's the raids I know is
Leviathan stall off spire stars yeah bro
that I think it's mostly because those
are free content now and they don't have
random roles so being as their year one
I don't think they want to continue to
let people use stuff from year one as
people by forsaken they get the last
wish raid as they buy shadow keep they
get garden of salvation I think they're
trying to keep the paid it because
somebody said it to me yesterday and and
that's actually what made sense they are
of the random role nature and they are
all sort of something currently that is
bought content I think that is why those
are gonna be able to live longer and
then last wish still being like the
oldest is probably gonna be the one that
expires first shout out to the check
score to the past skirt to the past and
crowd Arab that was an intro I know it's
sunsetting raids kognito has a problem
if this is I try to keep on fighting
raid but they're not gonna get you and
you can still get them you can still get
the weapon but it can only go up to 1060
raid weapons yeah some of them
it's Legendary's Anarchy's still gonna
hold 1,000 voice is still gonna hold
dirt terrible dad what about what about
wait are they special to you what about
aqueous that's an exotic that's an
exotic okay okay you're right besotted
all the exotics are midnight ku
that's a static rule ignite your dress
so that we can't get everyone we can't
we can't get a reissue no that might be
something they do later to revive
Leviathan but right now it's not right
now it's not people should not be using
midnight ku anymore anyway
I know somebody in jail it was that a
thing is what is the purpose of this my
thing is we the everything is fine but
we're crossing a new now territory would
raids that is surprising to me that's
the curve board I didn't expect it slits
legendaries that's been people forget
like legendaries encompasses a lot of
weapons they said legendaries not
exotics that wording hasn't changed I
mean if I go look at shattered throne
right now as a dungeon I don't even get
powerful gear from it okay so here's the
deal I mean that's the similar idea if
you go run last wit last which right now
is in powerful stuff okay so basically
we're gonna run let these old raids with
static drops no changes just for the
chance of ever gonna run all this on
we're gonna Rob just trying to get into
the mindset of how we're doing this why
we're doing this you know I'm saying
that that is the struggle I have please
talk me off the edge cuz I'm there what
is what happens if you go run Leviathan
right now you can still earn what you
could get a midnight coup as a drop you
could get an inaugural address and the
highest level that's gonna get up to as
a thousand sixty that content is what
level is Leviathan three four hundred
and all everything 750 now so find it
750 so you're gonna get guns there's
still gonna be a thousand sixty power
level max which we'll get to in a second
and you can still go take them back in
that rate if you want to go live that
glory days but what are you trying to go
into Leviathan get a midnight coup and
go use
year four is that your goal there my
goal is not that we have a different
bicep my thing is I struggle this is my
feeling raids to me or what make destiny
destiny right that is a unique feature a
unique mechanic that only they do and
they do it phenomenally I struggle and
we've talked about this many last words
where when the new ray comes out it
seems like all the other older raids are
no longer relevant yeah and I struggle
with that because at the end of the day
what is the purpose then you know I'm
saying like I don't I don't get that
meant at I am struggling with it okay so
I get like the mindset of me coming from
world of warcraft you play molten core
you got 40 people this is the same
reference it's a 40-person crazy raid
the new expansion comes out that thing
is mostly it goes ghost town unless
people want to experience it that's how
that wait that's not working so then you
- or just delete it there right I mean
depends on the players base there's this
built on servers they keep it in the
game yeah you could technically get 40
people together and go run it but the
new raid whatever it was got forget what
the second one is called um but yeah if
that new raid that's the that's the
pinnacle content the old ones not giving
you anything that's valuable it never
will mm it's from that year one when you
get into year three of World of Warcraft
versus all the bugs and everything which
I cannot remember the name of that raid
was the oh no one was going back and
playing molten core because it's not
gonna give you an email about a a two to
three op we got to play a two to three
hour raid and do all these encounters
but every drop is useless except for the
hope of you know the the end part or a
curious or the end part if you're
missing those key if you're missing
those things potentially yes which is a
random drop Anarchy's are random yeah
right these are no guarantee for weight
Anarchy right now so we gonna run
scourge for no reason because no drops
are substantial nothing helps you and
then we want to help you now in scourge
it's the same mop they learn that
literally the same boat right now if you
run scores right now none of the drops
help you my point is they are still
tight they're still exotics and
tied to that you can only get there
right right so why not
Jess reissue that loop is able to do
that as a way to give us a main later on
but right now no
it's gonna be interesting there is a
saying he does prestige Leviathan to
this day but he was saying it was for he
goes for heist at our Murrells which
we'll cover in a second we're actually
gonna be able to have a great way to
grind that stuff but right yeah yeah and
you're gonna be able to take that stuff
up to 1060 which is still higher than
you could do in any other game yay 160
you bat back of my socks but no the
whole point is like taking I mean the
fact that you can take Anarchy the fact
that you can take 1,000 voices the fact
that you can take legend of a koreas
forward I know exotics are immune in
this but in any other game those likely
wouldn't come forward either so exotics
have this rare immunity at this point
because they're afraid of pissing off
too many people you included mm-hmm
I mean now that's true but like anything
else from like a you know it's a year
one raid all those year one raids in
year four
so basically raids are disposable that's
what we got now raids are one day we
were you were there for the moments
formal raid some people delivery you get
to enjoy it for a year dude we have had
four clues for a year how long has that
felt enough bit raids are FOMO
interesting here dude I get it hey you
this is I'm trying to respect the
developer this is their content that
they want no one to play that they're
keeping in the game yeah that's it
no they're not we got we got to get this
part out here hear me out
that part is now wasted space you might
as well just delete it and just put
anarchy as a world drop there is no
purpose to right grab six people in
there and try to get that to me it's
wasted it's waste of resources so you
buy so just cut it out that that's all
I'm saying
and this is content they they themselves
don't want you know they want things to
be utilized and all this other stuff I
get it but they're having a team built
out this high-end content right to then
say okay we're all into the next one but
it still stays here it holds a place
you're you're dying on the Leviathans
hill you still have last wish and garden
of salvation that still have a life
beyond that year maybe they get me too
but laughs Leviathan is like three raids
and crime scourge and Kresta that's
because all that content was packed into
one year now crown and a scourge are
kind of an oddball in here because there
between last wish and garden but
Leviathan being the oldest you still
have like the main expansion raids going
farther than that year window maybe they
get two years maybe give they get a
little longer but again the the raids
themselves the big expansion raids are
getting a longer lifespan which is
you're worried so they're not like
disposable raids two to three years on
expansion raid oh how much longer do you
want that thing to live I just would
like some content I just would like I
just would like raids to be respected I
think that is the best thing destiny
does a lot let's put it this way we have
a lot of Sh of Famers we have a lot of
guests that come on the lash out CV
great job to be we just had who liked to
run the old raisin sure but people to
raids right yes we we all admit rate is
the pinnacle activity not our unit okay
all I'm saying is you know I'm saying
like why if they're gonna keep them
around anyway right they're not getting
rid of it so if you're not gonna get rid
of it why not just reissue so this yeah
we're not gonna do it right now I think
that's something you're getting into
their head do they may be like hey right
now we're doing this but they mention
the later the reissues and they may be
something be like hey we want to do a
season of what was the end of age of
triumph maybe they do an age of triumph
and they bring some stuff sack or they
do a rotating raid be like hey Leviathan
or mate and they may have plans for that
but right now yes they are not going to
give you stuff that's useful later so
it's gonna be for the experience which
is what some people do this stuff where
anyway do I need to go run somebody's
rule 11 right now probably not act to
get something for their time people like
to get listen a shout to shove the Dove
that's what I'm on they need to aim to
triumph or something with this joint
like that that would be the the nice set
maybe a plan for later but right now I'm
up so it's not happening and it's we
don't know right now we it's a question
I know right now we don't have that
answer right now we just have the
information we have and Leviathan not
help
yeah that's all I'm saying we shall see
so we have a picture of a loud low mi
which is that prime example or just tiny
little NAT my room so they show infusing
it's gonna look a little different you
have your current power level of the
weapon you have the power limit and then
you have the seasonal power cap so the
seasonal power cap and this also seems
to give away what next season's gonna be
its 1060 so likely that's the pinnacle
power cap that it's gonna get to
powerful gear is probably going to be
1050 so that's as high as that loud
lullaby is going to get when it goes
into season 12 those numbers are not
gonna change cuz that's where they're
capped at and we're gonna be able to see
which is gonna actually be very
interesting because if next season now
maybe they won't update it or something
I'm wondering honestly because then they
give away the power level because if I
look at any weapon I get this season I'm
gonna be able to see what it's powered
limit is to know how big the jumps are
so they've actually got to finally
commit it can't be 10 it can't be 40 it
can't be 50 they finally have to commit
to like a power increase going forward
because this is telling us in the future
you have to tell us what it asks yeah so
like is a fall expansion 200 then the
next seasons are 50 are they just like
decided and that's it because we're
finally gonna figure that one out but
this is what its gonna read us so you're
gonna know the final limit and that's
why it's going to tell you by seasons so
if you get to a season this thing's got
like a 1060 power or say this thing said
what would be a good example 1050 then
1250 say it was 30 say something you
pick up next season or even the one I've
got right now might say 1310 that's the
fall expansion and one more season
that's when I know that thing runs out
and then if I get to a season be like
hey the new power caps 1350 be like hope
this old weapons finally running out of
gas that you're gonna be able to see it
on your weapon and you're gonna kind of
get to know in advance how high that
thing's ever gonna get though trying to
give you that warning looking at that
weapon I know how far I know how far
this thing's gonna go so that's the main
piece of the picture no no you're good
so they
that picture of the example I know
you're battling people you're battling
me so those are the basics but you may
have additional questions as can I use
gear that has reached can I still use
gear that has reached max power level
yes you will always be able to equip and
use any piece of gear reaching the
player power cap is beneficial but not
strictly required for most activities
destiny you can continue to equip and
use your gear in all these activities so
as I said outside of the things I listed
you can use it everywhere else this
applies to armor as well as weapons yes
all legendary armor that proved up
provides power we'll have a max power
level starting in season 12 armor will
no longer have a seat now this is a good
thing
armor will no longer have a seasonally
rotating fourth mod slot instead there
will be a mod slot that accepts mods
introduced in the game throughout a full
year we've recognized that the current
need to replace your armor every two to
three seasons and horde armor is
unreasonable so armor is getting a one
year lifespan for that year and then the
expansion when you make that jump is
gonna send you into a new chunk of armor
mm hmm interesting
Rand's magnification we talked about
last week will give the ability to keep
your favorite looks and apply them to
new arm pieces with higher max power
levels when gear drops after its debut
season what will its max power level be
it will have the same max power level as
it did in its initial season no this is
different than gear that is reissued see
next question will we ever have well
gear ever have its max power level
updated not directly but gear can be
reissued same as we got like
interference and dire prop or old
fashion and stuff back this season these
reissued versions will have a new max
power level based on the season which
it's reissued we're gonna experiment
with how and when gears reissued into
the game throughout year 4 let us know
what you think of the different methods
you experienced I'll just cover the
final took piece yeah we're sure you
have more questions that aren't covered
above so please let us know we're
committed to destiny to continuing to
grow and evolve for years to come and a
part of that continued evolution is
curating the interesting exciting and
dynamic player sandbox the introduction
of max power level allow will allow us
to create exciting new gear more
frequently without significant concerns
of permanent power creep which is
unsustainable in any game this also
should open up creativity and an
experimental builds season over season
while letting you anticipate and prepare
for how the sandbox will change over
time all right so that's the other half
of this section for the Sun setting so
we've got armor in there as well armor
is gonna last for a full year for the
seasonal slot so it's gonna last and the
new expansions gonna be like the new
wave you could use your old stuff but
you'll have the new way of coming your
fall expansions same thing with the max
armor level and stuff of that nature
like you you are very very much right
now so listen and I hate to go back to
you know the raid thing oh my god very
good exactly it wasn't good so I wanted
you to talk and you know just want to
get my bars off you know again I no
one's fighting a mindset here right what
I'm asking is legitimately right for the
non hardcore because right now we are
thinking from our corpus
effective or I'm not seeing it for me
I'm also seeing it for a casual WD
Prescott that's what you gotta
understand when a new person comes in
right and he logs into destiny for the
first time and there's season of the new
season raid right that's what the
content is going to push him towards
that is the fastest trajectory to light
level and power right yep what is the
purpose that's what I'm trying to say
what incentive does that person have to
do the older car they don't it's the
little point right but that why does
there have to be incentives all around
there because again there's really no
incentive they're doing two things that
are just conflicting to me that age it
just seems weird to me you have all this
connect they talk about people logging
in and being confused on what to do
right and a big map doesn't this is
Bungie saying this right not me Bungie
is saying H on stream so again four
people do this Lord game play fun no
stop it they are confused when people
y'all make destiny payments come to me
and say cog there's so much stuff on the
map what am I supposed to go first
that's the truth you guys can fight it
because you guys are the hardcore but if
they're going to streamline you mile so
just cut it out now because at the end
of the day there's no reason to really
run that old content that's all I'm
saying till they giving a reason why it
shouldn't my thinking should even be
around safe spacing and let's free up
some hard drive that's it at this point
that's what I'm saying I'm done with I
just want to get those bars okay say
this was the destiny one you have
somebody come in in rise of iron be like
hey did you run did you enjoy the what's
the rise of iron raid I never remember
the name um
wrath little machine yeah you run wrath
new machine mhm
be like hey did you enjoy wrath of
machine yeah that was a cool experience
hey do you want to go see vault of glass
you're not gonna get anything that
helpful from it but do you want to go
see it
I'd love to show you you got some people
running through that's the you love
vault of glass you will die on the hill
the vault a glass of the best and you
have the experience to sha
no hold on you have the experience to
show someone a different rate are they
going to get new
from that that helps them know will they
understand more Lord be able to get a
feel for that experience experience the
exile Xin atheon yeah they'll get to see
it but are they gonna get anything
functionally helpful from it no but is
there stuff there's is there an
experience as their lower is their story
in there yes that's exactly the same
thing okay yeah it's just mind-boggling
that people to be forget how an
expansion in marketing works it's
mind-boggling to be that where people
login to the brand new expansion of
destiny that they are not going to be
line to the new content that's exactly
what they want everybody in the new
content right so to me it's just it's
just weird
it just feels conflicting messaging I
just don't understand it that's what I'm
saying
it's staying around as opposed to you
know the purpose so like I just I'm just
confused that's because I mean it is old
legacy content net to describe that way
but it doesn't mean that part of the
universe is completely let's just like
cut off yet they haven't removed
anything yet we haven't seen them do
that that may start happening in the
fall cuz we don't know if Titans gonna
explode right and maybe blog would it be
maybe the Leviathan drive about to say
that's would be the only thing that
would make sense to me that died you're
getting now we're meeting there I was
like if the lore piece does it but right
now the Leviathan still parked because
we have no reason for it to leave right
because here's my argument again this is
my last thing too is like they just said
Luke Smith just said things cannot stay
around the nature of my aid for those
why are you taking them away I'm telling
you what Luke said I he the boss
customer I didn't pay for that content
it's not going away yet it can't we all
think prom is gonna have to go we got to
choose between primary these are Luke's
words about content not sticking around
I'm just trying to assimilate to the
stuff that he said based on what's
happening now that's all I'm saying and
what you're saying could be very well
right
you could you could literally say yo
we're not prepared five years go get
destroyed you know I'm saying it's a big
cataclysmic event the Doritos come
through or last going and maybe that is
what's going to happen you know I'm
saying that's what I'm just trying to
understand future seasons and motive
patience for casuals and things of that
nature that's all I'm saying Leviathan
is pushing Oh easy
Leviathan is old so the question will be
honestly that will probably tell us more
is how long does last wish stay relevant
right now you get into where I'm going
what I'm saying that doesn't have a max
power yet so it's at least particular
gonna be that's a year to raid but could
make it through year four that's still
three years of length and if honestly if
you log into World of Warcraft right now
I'm not gonna be able to go run you
through molten core even if it even
exists on servers that are infinitely
large you I just want to tell people the
dirty truth that no one's talking about
which is raids are getting sunset y'all
let's keep it a buck let's stop dancing
around and be cute oh we couldn't do it
for the Lord we're gonna do it for the
love of the game we're gonna do it
because remember what we did in 88 no
they're getting sunsetted this is the
the greasing before it happens I'm
telling you that's what that's what I
ultimately was trying to get it Thank
You Chad I ain't fighting no no moil for
this I'm just telling you what's
happening y'all tryin to act y'all
trying to play these fake excuses about
y'all gonna still be doing these old
things Yeah right
I mean casuals excuse me that y'all
casuals excuse me any might an evolving
world then maybe that is the case we're
like the Leviathan drives away or
explodes by an affine ii ships and again
it's like hey I came to this game in
year four oh you remember that thing in
the Leviathan well you can't play
anymore what happened well that ship
exploded if they give the reason certain
things leave a decent narrative made my
man we did see we're back we're pocket
but they can't just leave all these
things on the map say yeah remember the
time when you hate new guys they have no
connection to this hey go in there and
do this mausoleum stuff but no way for a
casual player to go search out a raid
they probably don't even hardly know
it's there exactly yeah they definitely
III predict what you think is gonna
happen when Luke Smith says he I listen
to Luke Luke tells it what it is well
Luke says you ain't ready they blowing
stuff up stuff is getting eradicated off
this map
that's what's gonna happen that's my
prediction I'm standing on a hill all
right I'm done chat I'm done fighting we
can continue now Ironsides if they give
it a good storyline you're okay with
removing the raid
okay so prime example mm-hmm last wish
shattered throne at some point that
three week cycle I'm hoping has to end
right hoping has to actually finish has
to be resolved the Omkar dragon Dylan
karu whatever's powering that whatever
the death battery is doing all of that
stuff eventually has to get resolved and
if there's a point where the Dreaming
city is not stuck in this forever loop
that may be a way the Dreaming city
evolves into something else and if
that's the reason shattered throne
leaves or last wish is no longer around
because there's no reason to fight but
like wish dragon and they do something
else yeah I mean there's a point where
I'm sorry but most games don't word
unique space outside of World of
Warcraft is one of the only other games
that's lived this long very few things
have had this life no no no I'm like I'm
like this is any of somebody's to sing
so are you okay with if they give it a
storyline or you came from moving rate
yeah because the whole point is to
experience the newer content the fresh
content and stuff they've put in and if
something's four years old or three
years old and it's removed from the game
and especially if they even if it's just
remove it I'm okay mmm after that long
but if they give it a cool story that's
even better be like dude there was this
like plant eating ship pyramid ships
came in those things you've heard about
now they like attacked that Leviathan it
was like oh crap I'm out of here and it
like swallowed Nessus and drove away
yeah that was a crazy time man like that
but again but yes are you didn't
experience that rig well that was like
the year one raid from for like four
years ago we got a lot of other stuff to
do mmm that's the point where I get it I
get I just want get them to - I mean the
as far as Bungie they probably don't
want to do it I already know what's
going on thinking behind a curtain they
don't want to do it tell us right now
because that is going to probably most
likely spoil right what their narrative
thing right but that all I would that
was all my I was wanted to be clear
because could have started there by the
way it didn't make sense though yeah
y'all was acting like it made sense like
no you could still guys do it no man
like destiny had three years but
technically you could go play vault of
one before they did the age of triumph
you go play vault of glass some people
would do it there was no purpose but she
was good all saying the purpose of his
staying conflicted with his earlier
statements that was there's not much
what I was saying of an evolving world
about things not being static and all
this other stuff like Vegas dude what's
crazy how you exactly uh facts
[Music]
sunsetting obviously we seem okay you're
safe with exotics a lot of legendaries
going it's finally hitting people and
again some people aren't taking it well
some people are like hey my grind and
time investment for all these things I
finally got this God roll mm-hmm it's uh
it's just time that it's like you got a
move and the biggest thing is like there
was one of the Twitter on Twitter it was
King clayey I don't know if you guys
have seen him it's Andrew hops one of
the developers of Bungie now so fair
warning cursing coming up because I'm
quoting the tweet oh oh he fired off no
he just replied just literally he
replied to bungees table to cover this
stuff Oh
works on Bungie and he basically just
said this is how he described it and
this is somebody at destiny at Bungie so
sorry for the cursing but I do want to
quote him accurately we gotta be
accurate so you know how Rekluse shits
on everything in PvE weapons sunsetting
means we can add more weapons that [ __ ]
on everything and they can eventually
fall behind in power new weapons that
showed on everything can be added
without constant power creep I'm very
excited yeah so they can make their
recluses they can make their
mountaintops knowing that they don't
have to fight them in the meta forever
and that's what happens is it's the big
deal GE how would you relax what I was
gonna say is that where this is where
your argument is right as far as the
whole the initial thing with the Sun
setting is that the problem they've had
is when things get out of hand right
they've have to go to the nerf and the
all this other stuff and then they gotta
introduce new content it's out to the
cars coming by salute to the cars but um
tried a drag racing to get it in its
barrel racing oh no but on the whole
thing they interests have to introduce
new stuff as well as balance this stuff
that sometimes is a problem with the Sun
setting it kind of helps them out on the
back end right because if this thing
gets too ridiculous then it's like look
they only got three more months with
this thing and it's out of here anyway
and then you can introduce new thing and
I will say this in your defense which is
kind of exciting which affects your face
which is it is always I feel there is a
fun to not knowing what the meta is at
one point and the discovery of new
weapons right when you like yo you know
say like cuz all old stuff is now
tryouts and their trials in season 12
dude that's just like who knows yeah who
knows that it gonna be so everybody you
probably see are you proud of me I'm see
how I've assimilated into your Borg
mentality down which I know but all
jokes and I get it because it helps them
right and then it's like y'all what's
the new you know sand we gotta try out
everything and then that new stuff that
we get feels exciting it feels fresh you
don't have to worry about damn I got
recluse or an angry you know use this
something out you know there's 600
anyway because my current thing is
better than it and I get that part so in
that part is good now we got a breakdown
this this all middle with the whole um
with the slot after you finished the
bungee the bungee guy but we got to get
about that slap thing because that that
part is key what slot remember how about
they no longer had an international
fourth mod slot oh it's just the armor
is gonna last for a year yeah yeah yeah
so that'll be different to well we
talked about earlier how we feelin
specific my question is how are we
feeling specific because I know that was
a point of contention now that we had an
issue with it but it's for me it sounds
so gonna last season over so I'm ok with
it it lasts for a year and then and I
think that it has a better thematic fit
because armor that you get is going to
be able to use whatever mods to mess
with for a year and then that new
expansion news story push everything
gets going
or your new armor is gonna be working
with the new stuff and that's mmm
I mean I never mind this stuff because
I'm used to it like you get to a new
piece you get a new big power bump you
get a new expansion new armor yeah so
for me I suck and the armor and the mod
slot just being I'm not having to think
about the mod slot it's just like it
works this year pool was simple to me
for me where they won me over and they
got meeting to comply with this fart is
trans mom because my issue was there are
some pieces of armor that look cool as
hell and I look at some stuff now and
I'm like yo damn like this got the
season to the door mod so it's gonna be
gone soon you know that kind of you know
that really sucked if you really like
something cosmetically and it had it was
part of the old regime armor and you
know it's gonna go away and not be able
to use the newer mods that part was was
like that ever gave me some fear so now
that they have in transmog that is gonna
be cool because data leak because
there's there's some sense man that
really looked good and I want to
continue some of those looks
yeah I'm saying and that's why I like so
that was the happy medium for me and
we're completely good so army didn't
bother me no okay so the other side of
this is from Robby Stevens they talked
about rewards a little bit last week but
we have some juicy nuggets to share with
you on additional plans for next season
so in season 11 we'll trying something
new with how and where you can earn
seasonal rewards and now overall I think
this is kind of cool alright Friday my
throat alright so far every season in
year 3 has followed a formula where the
seasonal activity vex offensive sundial
bunkers SART our asked for a significant
amount of playtime to earn new rewards
while we believe that new content should
be one of the best places to earn new
rewards we also realized that destiny
too is a big game and it can be
frustrating to have so much of your
playtime dedicate or dictated by and
focusing solely on seasonal activities
the soda cat chat is fighting for swords
right now so your sword fight is a lot
out the cavities like yours only one
sword misses so down before oh yeah last
night I was like yeah distraction we
went through last night looked at how
many were going forward and okay so
before I get into what we're actually
talking about this is actually a good
thing to bring down because because you
have a couple things that you have to
consider when they start sunsetting
stuff for pinnacle activities take the
take nightfalls for example match game
is like always on now if they sunset
most of your gear you need to make sure
they enter and this is the whole other
side of the equation where I saw the big
arguments what they introduced as the
sunset is the biggest key to make sure
that this is successful if you take away
a recluse and introduced recluse be that
I have to go grind for again that sucks
I don't want a to go away just to get a
point one happened oh oh let me grab I
mean this is where it's on Bungie now
this is like I'm okay with the Sun
deciding to try and keep things fresh
but they need to be creative in their
weapon design at this point hopefully
the Sun setting allows them to do that
they need to make sure also we have a
decent slew of weapons that come every
season now we're getting potential
vendor refreshes which may help on some
fronts but you have to picture even like
arc solar and void you have shields and
match game that you have to face and
then if you compound that on top of the
artifact which may or may continue to
whatever level maybe they get a little
more broad but if you're like hey pulse
rifles are barrier and I go into like
some barrier thing and I need a pulse
rifle for range but I've only got like
one legendary pulse rifle and it's a
void in this strike has Ark and solar
shields what are you laughing at no this
funny you talk about it I'm just
laughing I mean just like I'm thinking
through so it's like hey only like
couple pulse rifles are coming forward
there's an ark in a solar but there's no
void pulse rifle this strike has void
guys and I need a pulse rifle for
barrier rounds mmm they got a make sure
and that's the key Bungie has to make
sure they be careful what they take away
what they balance in introduction what
they keep alive so that
years worth of rotation we always need
to make sure we have an arc a solar
avoid shotguns sidearms they need to
make sure we have enough variety to
always pick from
because if there's like if there's not
much there any kind of is definitely
gonna get to be it's gonna be were so
strict like then you're gonna be really
like like strictly limited in what you
can use so the biggest thing I saw a lot
of people I think captain McFly who is
on here applied to t-rex and he was
basically saying it's like I like the
idea behind it but it's on Bungie to
make sure what is introduced going
forward the new weapons are cool they're
fun to get they bounce everything out
what is introduced forward is just as
crucial as to the Sun setting to keep
things fresh so that was just a peace
honor to bring up new rad it says let me
say his that's his problem was sunset
and he said Bungie didn't curate the
weapon pool properly to be give it
there's some concerns I get that I get
that um it's like you say it's on them
hey this is their responsibility and you
know we gotta hold them to it because
again if you want people to sign up you
gotta have that pool properly curate it
you gotta have a lot of these proper
replacements you can have situations
like um I'm just using for example like
how remember when Tom this is a little
slightly different but remember when
Gardner Salvation raid came out and then
the pinnacles only you know I'm saying
it was split up incorrectly as far as
power level like the things got to be
thought out and that this is on them you
know I don't envy them or in this regard
I think they'll they'll do it they they
have to I mean if they thought this
through I mean I'm saying but we can't
have those type of situations happen
yeah sure I mean I feel like you've got
to I feel like for them I mean I look at
bows there's not that many in the first
place but the old literally the only bow
outside so the world bow point of the
stag you have an arc bow then you have a
crude Redemption and that's from last
wish not everybody has that one but
that's a kinetic bow and then we have
tyranny of heaven which is that was uh
that's last wish bow sorry Garden of
salvations accrued but there's literally
only three bows that are gonna work
mMmmm there's so I mean it's good there
gonna need to introduce more weapons on
a continual rotation to try and keep
that right it's gonna be more than we've
got this year yeah how's about say and
last point hazed here's the key for me
I'm not even as worried about that what
I would like I'm not worried but this is
what I want this is an opportunity for
them to do something cool and another
issue has always been bungee make perks
better or introduce new perks and that's
the key and that is their opportunity
they do that oh you don't say cuz we got
stuff that we got a lot of useless I
mean I can seek out here not doing that
friend we got a lot of stuff that likes
head seeker and kill clip shot the cool
guy but that man could turn you know
water in the wine you know how cool guy
is I know said he could that man will
take out some you know old-school joint
and he'll wreck shot with it and show
you the effectiveness and the usefulness
salute the cool guy that's my dude all
I'm saying is you know they've got this
is a perfect opportunity to really
attack the pool and kill a g-man so
let's see let's see that I would love
either all the perks getting better or
introducing new perks yeah we got to
bring cool guy back facts I like who
ladies fungi yeah that's what I do but
yeah that's kind of that that's the
biggest caveat to so much of this is the
fact that I mean black wings is saying
it's like they want a weapons 2.0 we've
got an armor 2.0 which I still think
needs to be 2.5 or 3.0 it's not quite
where you know it could use more it just
could use more just cuz where's the TV
not even going down that path play arm
like weapons 2.0 like giving them a like
big refresh in life and new perks and
that's kind of a thing that we need to
get some new love in as well so maybe
that's the way things go for something
of that nature I don't know but I mean
yeah new weapon perks besides outlaw
feeding frenzy rampage and kill clip or
multicam clips besides that I mean
that's what everybody tends to strive
for there's a couple I mean vorpal now
seems kind of popular but just shutting
down supers I mean there are or a little
bit about a possible bosses
but to my breach light yeah so I
mean I went through the clearing
yesterday trust me my subtle day right
I'd rather make sure my son my son down
weapons are okay right now right or now
as season okay that was a so sundial was
season nine you'll have it for nine ten
eleven and twelve but in December
sundials out oh yeah so for content yeah
sundown yeah so it lasts for one year of
content so season of dawn well sundial
it's just so weird it has been a year
it's like it's hit me it's been that
long it doesn't feel that way I feel
like we were just doing this stuff it's
so funny
give me a real good you have árboles
that's exactly what that is yeah you do
that's exactly it's a kinetic linear
fusion rifle that's a railgun so then
doesn't is supposed to do a match game
but we ain't gonna talk about that yeah
that's different
firing Lorelai yeah you were I mean
later on they're working on that but
again the fall expansion if they're
chunking a lot of this out needs to be a
pretty big infusion of variety and I
think that's what everybody wants and
needs to continue to have this stuff
fresh so yes all right back to where I
was sorry but that is actually a really
important topic I don't want to like
dumb that part down that is an insanely
huge piece they have to deliver on
variety and making desirable weapons
otherwise this whole Sun setting is
useless like you got to have something
you want to get otherwise there's no
point in getting rid of old stuff mm-hmm
okay
so season in season 11 seasonal rewards
will be dropping from completing core
activities strikes crucible gambit as
well as basically every other activity
in the game which they list below I'll
do that now just so he can get in order
public events dungeons raids adventures
nightmare hunts for just reckoning
menagerie an escalation protocol and
blind well anything you do in the game
can drop said season 11 rewards so for
every play session it gives you a chance
of earning seasonal loot in addition to
rewards season 11 will also feature two
returning weapons from season of undying
season have dawn and season awardee for
a total of six weapons that are free to
all players which is a nice so no but
that's a cool thing for them to say hey
if you wanted to get it now people who
didn't buy the season pass
can still go do strikes and get season
of Don weapons they can go work their
breech lights and stuff like that mm-hmm
once we've talked once we've talked
about some of the places where you'll
earn rewards in Season eleven now let's
talk about how you can influence those
rewards to chase God roles in high stat
armor now this is where I get a lot of
questions in chat yesterday about armor
armor grind right now is basically hey I
get a good stat roll why are you making
me get another heist a troll right which
is still something why I say armor 3.0
needs a little love to make some of that
stuff more fresh give it like I want you
know set bonuses and stuff that really
starts setting things apart and make it
like new viable things to go after each
year because yeah right now if I have a
64 stat roll chest armor right your
goodness and why do I need another one
but especially if you're like hey they
only last for a year well damnit why do
I have to go in a year for sure get
another one unless there's a reason
that's where again I say armor needs
something else
new set bonuses new yearly addition
something the mods are a tiny start but
again if that's all it is I still know
it's working but again not quite done
right so over the last few seasons we've
introduced weapon bounties that give you
agency to chase specific rewards while
addressing while addressing bounty
fatigue with will be an effort that
extends beyond year 3 so they're working
on the bounty of fatigue we've talked
about that for the upcoming season we've
moved away from weapon bounties as part
of that effort positive instead we're
introducing a new type of quote redacted
in Graham again probably story stuff who
knows that contains the majority of
season 11 rewards by spending seasonal
currency you can influence the contents
of that Engram to clear up any confusion
let's imagine we launched the redacted
in Graham this season imagine the same
Graham contain all of the season worthy
weapons and armor now imagine you could
take this Engram to a seraph bunker
spend some currency to focus the
contents of this in Graham so it only
contains the seven Seraph SMG and
shotgun so any of those random seasonal
drops that you would get by clearing
bunkers by doing these public events by
doing anything that would get you those
seasonal engrams now you could focus and
be like okay shotguns SMG they've got
some decent rolls
I only want to see those two drop so I
can focus in and work on those God roles
and you can do that anywhere right
that's pretty cool that that's pretty
powerful we're not gonna negate this
this is a cool change and it's towards a
goal it's just I was surprised they
actually said they were gonna bring some
stuff back that was the part that really
threw me off a little bit I think it's a
nice nudge cuz they're free cuz they
mentioned specifically that are free to
all players they've been part of the
annual season pass like purchases let
some free players enjoy some of that
stuff for a little while yeah this is
gonna be a grind gonna be real for some
of this man cuz people gonna want to
want to get some of that come with that
stuff and then the fact that you can go
towards a specific path that's what made
I think they started introducing a lot
of this stuff son sundial II I would say
and um was that the was the name of the
things we used to work on in the sundial
with the fractal mean I've got the
naming them things but um wait I lost
balance and all that yeah it's like what
kind of in a way you know say like you
you have a more direct refined approach
to things and I think the community has
responded well to that kind of stuff you
know I'm saying as a bobble s thank you
guys thank you without a while I was
blanking on that but um I think that you
know I think it's a good thing I think
it's a good thing this is cool man
because you want to you want to respect
people's grind you know and not just
this random crazy loop pill that gets
bigger and bigger with you know without
the shot of trying to get the specific
type of things at least the archetypes
of things you want right so they say by
focusing and this is the other piece
that honestly helps a lot of people with
the other question of armor by focusing
engrams in Season eleven you can choose
your awards this includes the ability
once you've earned it so you probably
won't do it early in the season but you
do have a progress point to focus Engram
so they only contain Season eleven high
stat packages so you can aim
specifically for high stat armor roles
now that's big now that's the big
question when somebody's like hey why am
I gonna grind well if you're gonna and
we'll get more how often these things
are gonna drop you're gonna see these
alive
if you focus up on high stat roles plus
you're getting them all the time I feel
like we're gonna have a lot of high stat
packages yes a physic so all three
players and season pass owners will
receive redacted engrams while playing
season 11
however only season pass owners will can
access the full suite of focusing
categories here's a preview of the in
gram focusing categories that all
players can access after season 11
season 11 focus focusing reduces the
number of awards in the Engram so it
only contains season 11 Armour previous
season weapon focusing converts the
rewards in the Engram so it only
contains the six weapons that are
returning that's just a couple so you
can focus on the old weapons maybe you
missed those you could focus on a couple
of the new ones that are coming you
could focus on just armor in that season
if you unlock it it's armor and in high
stat roles you can really narrow this
thing down while season win season 11
launches all players will get access to
three focusing categories season pass
owners will have access to an additional
15 so if you get that season pass you're
really gonna be able to drill down very
very hardcore what you want to grind out
I was I would say shot behind sighs he's
making a good point they're actually
introducing on a sub on a certain level
d1 remember d1 when you would get
certain engrams you had the choice of
picking armor armor all the way feel
like life is that the vendors and stuff
like you can do this is this is some d1
callbacks but honored deeper a more you
know robust level so to speak so it's
like I was because I saw sounds I was
literally what I could visualize
remember used to have a little purple
Engram and he's to have the helmet and
he's every weapon yeah you know saying
and that that you it is so I mean it is
interesting then we come coming full
circle with this continue
Oh shove that shove the death was asking
slate haven't logged in a while what's
the max infusion level for Wendigo
Wendigo like many other things that have
been a little older is probably gonna
cap out whatever next season's power
levels gonna be that's where it's high
it's gonna be so going into the fall
expansion in September Windigo like many
other things will not be able to go
above season 11 for power level now this
is the point in addition to the above
list of all the places you can earn
these engrams the Renekton Engram have a
chance to drop when defeating combatants
anywhere in the system just like
legendary engrams they share the same
loop pool as legendary engrams and when
you hit that loop pool you have a 66%
chance to earn a redacted in gram 34
percent chance they're in legendary so
you're really gonna have these redacted
engrams a lot probably if you play a lot
they're gonna be everybody's yeah yeah
and look at all the activities that they
listed it right yep this is pretty much
everything more activities like Bonacci
staying around okay it's 11 this is 11
is correct
we hope this preview this is some more
now if Alyssa's up for now I guess for
now till things start blowing up exactly
we hope this preview of season 11 give
some insights yet or the other
shout out by the way for the Guardians
heart seven hundred eighty-eight
thousand they broke their charity goal
that's freaking awesome guys 39 Bungie
banners shout out to Ares who had his oh
yes hello they got a small hotfix coming
on Tuesday a couple air codes are still
hanging around they still got a couple
issues you guys can read through that if
you want to vinyl lion that really kind
of matters and we'll kind of talk about
this in areas if you want to chime in on
this one if you're still out there or
anybody else we hope you enjoy the
little preview we gave you of the new
redacted in Graham coming next season
next week we'll share more changes
coming and how you'll earn rewards in
Season eleven they've talked about
rewards like three weeks in a row three
weeks in a row yeah salute though some
of you know what a world loot pool is
many of you have no idea what I'm
talking about don't worry we'll talk
next week so this is the other thing as
a world loop pool now
I tweeted appalled Tassie because he
said one thing because he was kind of
excited I was like is this what I'm
picturing because what I imagined coming
from world and again Luke Smith did come
from world so it's probably not
completely out of relative question yeah
so you had the big raids which I didn't
always have a big group to go into
because it was just a larger group and
part of claims and stuff but you had
smaller like dungeons you could go run
that we're like a step above which is
still something I wish they would do
with strikes but it was like this is how
you would kind of get the the pre raid
set this is how you would get that like
next level but not like the full in game
but it's how you can write this is close
as you could get to be ready right and
the thing is there's like there's so
many different dungeons and stuff around
and there are certain ones like okay in
this dungeon in this branch of this
dungeon because there might be three I
know from this specific boss I can heard
earn the headpiece for my set right and
that's like literally in the world
that's a set drop over there now part of
this is what he was saying is like
strike specific loot mm-hmm that's a big
question it's like hey are there certain
things that we're gonna be able to earn
in a world blue pool the stuff that's
out in the world but I really want to
know what their definition of it is but
if there are certain things to earn in
certain places like this boss can drop
these five things right like that's just
how that is as opposed to just an Engram
right so it's more specific drops from
certain places how I read that I don't
know if you had any thoughts about that
one at all but I it has potential to be
cool if we talk like strike specific
loot or things of that nature I'm really
kind of curious what they mean by it I
didn't know if anybody had any thoughts
or opinions because that one could be
interpreted a whole bunch of many
different ways yeah it's very vague um I
don't know I mean I could see you know
both scenarios obviously we've had the
specific being kind of as a part the
specific loot drop at a specific boss
thing kind of kind of existed around for
for dusty for a while yeah this is this
is interesting you know if they go the
other the other side you know saying but
I don't know it's very intricate of the
fact that we have gotten
this level of transparency for down to
three level weeks in a row and we're
still no rewards which is funny but um I
think this is cool I think I think um I
know if they say look so maybe this
without my guess I'm gonna take a shot
at it my guess is what I obviously what
I was talking about is getting all hot
and bothered earlier about the whole you
know rain stuff and maybe this presents
a scenario where anarchy and one cave
voices become part of that pool you know
I'm saying maybe maybe I don't know that
this this could go so many different
ways I don't I don't know all the way
what they what the thought process is
but it is interesting that they utilize
that verbage world Lou pool interesting
interesting terminology to me yeah it's
like cuz that's just like it in
conceptually it's like strikes to
exclusive loot we all want that and
specifically earning certain things from
certain places in theory could be what
that is like certain raid bosses would
specifically like this raid boss can
drop this bow for said guy like that was
a World of Warcraft thing so like the
hunters could get this weapon from here
if you beat that boss and you don't get
it okay you're not getting that weapon
because the next boss is working on this
type of stuff so there were there was
always a weird like this set like a an
enemy having a Slyke the specific
enemies having certain drops that that's
where you can get that one thing being
in more places
what if lost sectors can have like
specific things in certain places or
grow strikes and night falls yeah spread
that loot around a little bit more yeah
dungeon like the dungeon encounter this
one drops the lake I almost feel like ya
have certain raids you can like in raids
certain encounters drop certain things
what I mean I'm trying to think is that
even now late are there only certain
things you can get in certain places
besides exotic like if I do yeah Garden
of salvation are there only certain
things that drop from the final boss
versus the first boss there's stuff like
that right there's stuff like that and
then there's Ray's that are attached to
catalysts shout-out to sleeper simulate
which that's
hey let me tell you right now that's
where I will definitely that fight you
they throw that bad boy in the world
loop pool and keep it out of that
foolishness of random chess in a raid
for a catalyst that I you don't really
want
so did I don't know man I think I think
it made me go in that direction with my
prediction maybe that direction with the
cataclysmic possible story event yeah
because you're gonna need a play he's
still gonna have I need a source you're
still gonna need a source to where can
we get those things you know I'm saying
yeah shout out to yo shout out the new
red still trying to get the Telesto yeah
yeah shout out to me like I despise
spire of stop stars
I just want my damn every time I get in
there I just want my sleeper simulant
catalyst that's literally all I want and
I haven't gotten it yet goes everyone
else or random chance yeah
yeah and you only got like one shot at
it so we come reset and it's a very
annoying race you have to what go a
specific loadout
no anyway I think that's what we could
be doing that's that's bugger and then
and then sunset
timrie I mean if there's an if they're
if they handle it in kind of a cool way
yeah it's how they will it's how this
game and this is where I wanted to kind
of bring all back full circle to you
you know this whole argument that we've
been going on for a little while that d3
is coming oh oh good question how
confident do you feel about d3 coming as
this information keeps being doled out
to us definitely feels pushback
definitely first push back how far do
you see it now I mean I know we joked
about how long stuff could last but
seriously I know we thought like 20 21
but 21 that does anything gets on the
taste don't feel 20 21
this feels towards way or 2 3 because my
gut now I do push it back here because
if you're doing all of this right in
your son setting
you're not gonna sunsets up then to then
be like yo here's the new game yeah that
that planing that longevity of like how
things are gonna function isn't that
short of a time period it may be
function that way in d3 when we can get
in there but this still feels like
they're building for a longer that year
for year year for is 2020 you're 5 in
September would be 2021 year six would
be 2022 and he said year four five and
six so Prescott's over there say in 2023
Dakota say in 2024 oh wow yeah go far
I'm gonna go 2020 to UM 2020 a theory if
you go year four or five and six because
they've literally said those words and
that's 2027 or five or six well if I'm
Dave where they say five five or six I'm
just I missed it it lasts uh it was
literally last week mm-hmm they
literally said things are gonna be for
year 4 year 5 and year 6 they fret they
literally had that hold on let me look
you gotta send me now I got a dig I
gotta get the proof vanity accessories
and changes okay core playlist crucible
core playlist reward changes we will
create new sets like this each year year
4 year 5 year 6 etc so again that still
kind of open-ended but they're just
open-ended oh yeah that's opening that
doesn't necessarily mean it's not gonna
happen but they still keep giving this
like lifespan that is pretty lengthy to
it is the key
yeah it's it didn't listen it ain't
happening on next gingers yet what what
wait but we are getting something
they're gonna be after here's that
here's the caveat they're going to be at
the Summer Games Fest this year I know
it now can't wax Jen so well you know
that you know that's two things one is
gonna promote the cataclysmic event
that's gonna happen in September right
I feel what has happened now is kind of
this is rise of iron 2.0 saga all over
again the edge of triumph right now yep
this is technically we this was supposed
to be d3 pyramids they have now made
that into fall we're gonna ride this out
during this current destiny game and d3
is something completely different now
now that's the vibe I'm getting so I my
prediction is probably year 2022 2023 I
think they still will make a new game
but you can't make it now you can't make
it in the next one year until you you
you're doing too many long-term goals in
d2 right now this is what it's way too
many what's up em Jana boss what's going
on
um yeah man so I I think they are
definitely keeping us around for a
little bit longer there's no doubt now
if you think about that if we go destiny
one at three years
if this goes 2023 last nine years they
said this was a ten-year franchise here
he comes
no I'm scared like do you think they
keep do you know I was like I mean I
want a d3 but that takes this franchise
beyond their 10-year plan I mean that's
really making them probably if they do a
d3 that's another few years you're
getting 1213 years potentially with
disfranchise do you think they ever get
tired of it to a point but I was like on
the other side they did pay a hundred
sixty million dollars from Activision
for it so you got to imagine they had a
pretty long plan for this thing I just
like they said hey this is gonna be
French eyes the last for ten years
if D 2 goes to year 6 potentially we're
saying 2023 that's nine years yeah that
isn't that just lengthwise that's
getting there
yeah I mean again that was Activision
top though so I don't want to get too
caught up with that but that was during
the active in days when they were saying
all that stuff there on their own
um I just think that they're on their
own time schedule to be honest I just
think that this is them this is a new
frontier now right this is yo we are
free you know I think this season is
really they're really gonna be more
acclimated on their own as opposed to
that initial break of shadow keep and
jump right into the yeah ever versus
kind of telling them of that too like
hey we gotta yeah but a whole bunch of
stuff in there to try and survive okay
we've survived now let's build the build
the game we want to and we would like to
build right the quit the issues going to
be next gen hard way upgrade you better
give me 60 frames per second on cause
Valhalla is not they want that 4k Bungie
no dude first-person shooter has to be
halo most likely will be for sure
there's no way that's not doesn't need
to has to be 60 frames there's no way
it's not alright Forte says he thinks
they're gonna drop the two and just call
it like you don't guess to the infinite
that's to be forever started twenty
twenty ten they did that in the fall
just literally we're now called destiny
and just drop the two now just to set
that precedent
anything is possible that we're in a new
frontier they control their destiny
literally fun so it's just like
nothing's gonna surprise me but I have
to admit you like what you're saying is
this none of this screams we are ready
to jump to an to add a three to anything
right now in at least a year or two yeah
that yeah that's what I said all these
planes you do not make these plans if
you plan on getting a new game pretty
soon but Aquis you know you said even
with the low enthusiasm for to see the
community engagement oh yeah this
community any game you know I'm saying
all child aside for you so little
brother yeah that was fun man good to
see you yeah we got to see we got to see
man this is uncharted territory as long
as my thing as long as the engine is
kept up good as long as they're doing
these paths oh man that is the the
issues though it's like it's showing age
and certain points until to like limp
this thing along for a while I'm hoping
there might be like background work or
we login or like man this feels like it
feels good like if they can do those
types of things but man that's such deep
deep level coding at an engine level
that's rough man
and he's my fear is I'm with you because
at 2022
this game is gonna feel ancient this
game going look oh look like yo like
that's I'm like can we get these you
know better graphical engine can we get
that uh not unreal what bunch of you
know I don't know obviously I think
that's probably proprietary I don't know
if I've ever heard right sorry is a
proprietary engine no let me shout out
to - I have any buy of Ares around who's
my techies in it shuttle - who knows in
a game before taehu who knows what
engine bungees using for destiny I
forget off top somebody's like I believe
it's Bungie zone engine somebody was
like is it frostbite is it something
else is like very proprietary in my
people time Terry always so unreal but
at the end of the day this thing gonna
be looking long tiger
people say I got a tiger in here so but
yeah yeah I know more as we people are
thinking about is there gonna be a
destiny battle battle royale and it's
like yeah that engine wouldn't handle
that all I'm saying is
this game gonna be looking very spooky
next - all right put it this way even
though the games I'm about to say people
say oh they are failures or whatever
anthem reboot or next-gen consoles oh
dude that would look gun directly on
like yeah a real updater for us by doing
next-gen yeah the game anthem already
looked good yeah right but god that
would look yeah gorgeous got dead
division or any new a model run - Nick
same battle for any new thing that comes
on the scene and we gonna be out here
looking with this we're just uh and
that's one of those like I mean World of
Warcraft Lake has is dated per say you
go and it still doesn't look fancy and
they've had some like kind of graphical
refreshes and stuff but I mean it's
still the 14 year old game it can only
look so good to a point right and that's
where I wonder that's the big pieces you
have the netcode you have the engine you
have and again if you go to next-gen
consoles and you really want to take
advantage of that's where a d3 it's not
the canyon between each play space that
you have to funnel into your Prescott is
so messy right now he looks gorgeous I
heard it looks amazing
he's so messy but the Prescott is gonna
be looking like it's gonna look spoke -
yeah we're gonna be playing minecraft
dungeons when people are playing Diablo
4 like that's you can't be having me run
around with this old pickup truck and
everybody got the new you know the new
platinum edition Ford f-150 extended cab
with Pearlman I'm not even a truck
person I'm making stuff up but it's
gonna be looking spooky for rest of it
that's by worries like I get it Suns
setting all this stuff has to happen I
get it but listen I Asajj we know what
happens when anything goes against this
did we no but
casuals gravitate towards eye candy and
if something looks phenomenal and they
correct their mistakes that's a problem
if we're still running with this engine
the way it is you know I'm saying
but that's why I'm hoping that's why I'm
still sticking to I'm holding part of it
is hope but part of it is yo 2022 that's
2020 New Castle's 2021 okay that's way
too man
yeah that would be it'd be with this
thing Oh 2022 would be basically two
full years on next-gen yeah I mean
especially people that were developing
games before the release of next-gen
which obviously people are with God
following other stuff like this you're
at a point where like next-gen games
that were developed before and develop
like you're gonna be two years in seeing
things like God of War to potentially I
mean that's gonna look holy hell that's
gonna look amazing you compare that to
destiny um you can't just do like uh you
can't do a hey it's gonna be on next-gen
consoles it's not gonna look that good
it's not gonna look that much better
yeah I mean it's good like I said you
have your framerate you'll have effects
or whatever I'll be let you gonna throw
rate racing on okay great but at the end
of the day it's like you've got to
create a new engine you got to create a
new game at some point and that's where
I'm hoping you know saying I hope a lot
of this stuff is a band-aid for a year
to two as opposed to three to four like
brother playing it is engine for that
long
you know just me I was like that I will
I won't be very curious when we really
start to see games that utilize the SSD
for loading so the first time we see an
uncharted or a Tomb Raider that doesn't
have any shimmy through a little rocks
there close together or file through
this little bookcase in this house I can
get into the next room so loading is not
done cheaply like that when we see those
types of things actually like utilized
then I will be very very curious as to
what like mm-hmm
cuz like you picture destiny does that
everywhere every lick named play space
you go through your little tunner your
curvature your little broken highway and
etz that connects each path like all of
those won't technically be required if
you'd remove three to that level and we
and then think about all the cool
innovative things we were talking about
right like you know i can try many
frames per second either fax 30 30
frames in the bushes um think about all
the cool things that you can get away
with new tech with expanding fire teams
patrol spaces 600 nice holy yeah I'm
saying like these are cool like even if
they kept current you know I'm saying
but if they just with a new engine and
able to expand upon things to some level
and then have the SSD loading in those a
systems faster SSDs man the potential in
the game could be really cool and I
worry you know waiting that long if the
base is still gonna be as strong as it
is I mean we're gonna be here cuz we
love destiny
but again casuals are what's gonna keep
this thing alive to people to keep
coming back and you've got to entice
them with with shiny things and new
things and new features and I don't know
how much more they can get out of what
they have right now
mmm you know I'm saying so that's gonna
be the long-term question how long can
they do this you know saying if give me
a planet to publicise feeling of it and
I'll be happy
hey man I hate you rather how to see
interesting that's an interesting time
in it really really is that's look man
we did a really nice eulogy today some
proper burial to some bings
and that list when you
when I sat there and was working through
like my vault clean out last night and
we were just looking at collections of
all the stuff that won't be going into
just literally into year four that's
already a big chunk and it kind of gave
warning but it's set in yesterday pretty
hard yeah yeah it sets in it's in it you
see the head of doom and gloom this is
interesting times man
but listen exciting in the immediate
future right immediate future we're
going to get some cool cataclysmic story
stuff we're gonna get fresh new pool of
weapons armor I think they're handling
that for the most part the right way you
know and I'm making new exciting again
that kind of stuff is cool and you know
especially the seasonal mod stuff and
all that so I can't wait man I can't
wait actually for September which is the
accelerated pyramids being here you know
same and the result
oh yeah they were saying you can tell he
bunt as plate d2 for a long time cuz I
had a solar play of the game yeah yeah I
had some of those that didn't quite get
shifted over but oh wow
solar back in the day man we can
speculate for a while but I was like I
feel like at this point the probably
wrapped up everything for the day gotta
let this man get some sleep
oh it's important I gotta get whiskey
Joe he said they can keep this game
going slow for a couple years if they
fix trials and stop the network preach I
really don't care what else they do
fixing those two things on your whiskey
Joe you are onto something I've been
that's my I've been fevered to death
talking about consecutively like lately
it's been bad yeah I'm not starving it's
a bit bad and that's why I'm like why
last week when we talked with CB great
when they're talking about trials loot
and I said forget hoes listen to
somebody said it well it's like trials
like if we got new trials route next
season or even September because it's
gonna be coming in December if you got
new trials route loot but it's not fixed
won't matter
yeah so they gotta fix that stuff and
which is honestly take the time let them
fix it up and then like when they get
that next push of trials hopefully it's
good but yeah the trials PC stuff is
just nasty right now the power is nasty
shad the cross I loaded to the tower
there's no one near I know I'm about to
get beaver not I got beaver like three
in a row it'd be back to back to back to
the point I was so frustrated I was
gonna be without of things I'm getting
beer out of matches I'll just like man
what is going on they've got to get a
hold on this man
yeah Bungie says by Anakin actually get
my files without you know hundred to one
and up twenty down you're fine
mind slow but I still I don't actually
get that many errors yeah I mean this is
a space I mean basically this is
happening I think it will be good for
the game but Bungie does have to deliver
and I think that's the biggest thing
about this Bungie having to make what
we're doing now and make the people who
feel like I don't care as much because I
know I've expected this and it just
stuff had longer life than it should but
if you are gonna get to that point where
people have had these investments like
shout outs a pyro who just got red Rex
like he was checking that box nicely
that's like but it but I mean yeah you
can use that in control forever that's
like so they gotta have their
perspectives and make sure that stuff's
in Peru but overall Bungie has to
deliver in the fall when this stuff goes
with a large chunk of new stuff to make
sure we always have a nice fresh loop
pool with cool perks and fun stuff that
has variety because if I have like one
bow I can pick from and then I get one
more yeah I'm gonna need a little bit a
little more love than that
yeah I'm confident that never they they
have that they gotta have the stats as
far as you know weapons as far as the
archetypes which architects they don't
have enough of what they got to
reintroduce I'm confident that they are
very number hair heavy so I'm not really
worried about that the key comes down to
you know obviously the implementation
and stuff like that but I think they
will be fine never got to be honest I do
think we find never go
Chet's a slayer they need to add another
hammer it's the beaver hammer and
they're playing whack-a-mole that's
awesome salute salute all right well
thank you guys very much
kognito wrap them up if you got anything
going on this weekend let them know or
where they can find you sir Jim at Lord
kognito on Twitter all that good stuff
and uh I'm a podcast every Sunday 1:00
p.m. Eastern actually streaming on
Twitch now we're voting on twitch
multi-platform except you you thought
you follow me on Twitter you don't like
youtube please follow all my podcasts on
Twitch and mixer we're on both platforms
including on youtube so pick a platform
you can even interact the West there we
do the chat I try to talk to all the
different platforms simultaneously 1:00
p.m. Eastern it would just be the laws
no special guest this week just talking
about all the hotness that went down
this week PlayStation 5 engine unreal
and of course it goes to Tsushima you
already know we're gonna talk about that
and a lot of the gaming stuff man but
yeah check us out and um yeah man you
know that's what I like to shout out
with the best damn fast across we gotta
[ __ ] as you never heard before
you don't say he hates what I said but I
said all those laughs whoops - so they
don't kick is the biggest supporter he
is all shot - can he be riding man King
yet King gives me get it back he gonna
you gonna definitely be this bag on
Sunday it's gonna be a nice but yeah
again if you if you want to watch the
content again for it just to reiterate
if you're on Twitch but like you're here
and you want to watch hour-long podcast
we want which we simultaneously stream
so come check us out man we're gonna
talk games and listen to my crazy Lord
brethren and talk a multi-platform stuff
absolutely I was like for me you guys
know I'll be doing this I'm still
working through neo so we're over
halfway through working towards that one
it feels like I'm not gonna get Final
Fantasy 7 in before Last of Us so Last
of Us is bigger and I do want to play
that fresh not to be spoiled as much as
I've avoided spoilers so far so yeah I
want to kind of kick that when they go
in verse 1 I want to replay the first
one before I get into it I haven't done
enough on ps4 it's not a short game man
you kind of got to get on that sooner
than later no I got to get my stash
short I know I gotta get going you know
mm-hmm but yeah I'm about to so you guys
come find me twitch Twitter YouTube eb o
& t is if you
the cheetah and my name you have found
me so we were gonna go send a raid over
to I know an awesome streamers she does
some amazing raids and stuff like that
so it so be Katie cat okay so we're
gonna send the love over there to her I
definitely find her on twitch you guys
listen to this on audio but thank you
all very much
keep your record incognito we'll wrap it
up and then for all of you guys episode
103 May 15th this has been an awesome
one thank you guys very much kind of
crazy topics but the world has changed
and so thank you guys very much and it
has been the last word